adrian will be presenting it though
thank you welcome to everyone this
afternoon's planning committee meeting
before we start i'd like would like to
confirm which committee members and
officers are present
thank you chair so joining us today for
this virtual meeting
are councillors william armitage
andrew cooper peter elliott
mark foster betty hill
heather liggett mo potts
alan powell tracy reader
cathy rouse and yourself as the chair of
parent committee
diana rough also in attendance today
you have the planning officers um alice
lockett
sue reith and adrian kirkham members of
the governance team who are supporting
this meeting and you
jim fields and from legal thank you
chair
thank you as you know we have a protocol
in place for meeting in this virtual way
which i would now like the meeting
facilitator to read out
thank you chair um this is just a
reminder to all members to address and
behave as if in the council chamber in
accordance with the etiquette for
virtual meetings
a reminder this meeting is being
streamed and it is being recorded
if members would kindly speak through
the chair so that's remaining muted
when not invited to speak and to
indicate to speak
please either raise your hand or write
speak in the chat bar
um if you'd be kind enough to turn on
your closed captions if they're not
already enabled i will
do some prompts to just let you know
that your request to speak has already
been picked up
and if you'd be kind enough also to
introduce yourself when you do speak
so for example counselor x representing
y ward
voting for this meeting will be
undertaken by roll call for every
application
please just be mindful of your home
surroundings and make sure that you
appear alone on camera and to keep
yourself on camera at all times where
possible
just to let you know chair that also in
attendance now is councillor ross
shipman
[Music]
[Music]
all right cheers
well thank you michelle we have
apologies from councillors huckabee
councillors barry and we've just
received apology from uh councillor
jackie
thank you
[Music]
okay
so did you get that chair i did thank
you okay thanks
just scribbled them down are there any
declarations of interest
okay i'm going to be speaking against
the first item
i've already submitted something against
the first application and then i'm going
to have to leave actually after that
item so
are you taking place in the um debate
or the voting ros before you leave
no i won't i'm going to speak against it
i think it would be fair if i were
voting against that so you'll be
speaking so basically you'll be speaking
and then leaving the meeting and having
no part and as a discussion or
determination
that's correct okay thank you thank you
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
interest and or other interests not
already on the register if any item on
the agenda
they are asked to withdraw from the
meeting at the appropriate time
other than councillor shipments have we
received any
a non-received chair thank you
are there any to be declared
no indications chair no thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on tuesday the 12th of january 2020
are we happy that they are a correct
record and if so is there a mover
counselor counselor art footage
all those youtubers
thank you any against
all right no abstentions thank you
emotion was carried
we will now start the main body of the
afternoon which is the application
and as you can see with four
applications each of which has its own
report
marked as items four to seven i'm happy
with this and intend to consider them in
that
order however before we do this i would
like the clerk to explain for the
benefit of members speakers and the
public who are watching
on youtube how they will be dealt with
[Music]
right thank you chair uh this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting we will consider the four
applications in the order that they are
set out on the agenda
although there may be a break between
them
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers
to refer members to any late comments or
updates received
since the agenda was issued
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors
then the applicant or their agent to
speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate
by the committee members and then
ultimately by determination by a vote
a note for speakers once the application
you've come to speak on has been dealt
with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain then pl please
mute your microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point now as you are aware
this meeting is being live streamed
the council will make a recording for
the purposes of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
please note that others may also record
the live stream from the internet
thank you chair thank you we move on to
the first application
which is ned forward slash twenty four
slash
zero zero five zero six four slash tpo
at old top ten in line with our normal
practice i'm going to ask the planning
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that they've been
produced and for the planning manager to
give a brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might find it
difficult to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
until the end there'll be plenty of time
for questions later
and we'll start with the planning
officer the case officer i believe
that's alice
yep thank you chair
um okay
go to the first one thank you
um this application is for the removal
of 34 poplars covered by nedc tpo
number six at landlords and to the north
and west of the poplars anchor bowl road
old topton
this application was brought to planning
committee in september
and it was requested at the time that
the local plant planning authority
commissioned a survey of the trees
awa tree consultants carried out the
survey in december 2020
awa were only able to identify 34
popular as present at the site
seven fewer than the 41 in the original
application title
this was explained by the applicant as
being due to the differences in survey
methods
including the inclusion of trees that
were already dead in their own survey
trees that have died since their survey
and
other species it was therefore agreed
that this application title should be
amended to apply
to the remaining 34 poplars
the trees are located on the southern
boundary of the site next to the
dwellings known as the poplars and the
gables
come with the next site that's it and
they are a strip of trees
recorded as area one on the tpo schedule
the area tpo runs from the road to the
east for approximately 100 meters
westwards
and it is approximately 20 meters right
wide
the hedge run sorry a hedge runs below
the area of trees to the south
and forms the boundary with the poplars
and the gables
this hedge is not subject to the tpo and
indeed hedges cannot be subject to tpos
the tpo protect protects trees which
make a significant contribution to the
immunity of the area
can we have the next slide please thank
you
um so you can see the trees in this
aerial photo
and you can see the poplars and the
gables to the south of them
uh next slide please and this is a
picture of them
taken from the field which is now the
development site
um next slide please
this is a view of the trees from the
from the north on anchor board road
the trees are visual visually prominent
when traveling from the north
although this will be reduced by the new
housing which has been granted
permission on this part of the site
next slide please and this is the view
from
the south if you're coming along
anchorable road from the south
and then the next slide please
um oh sorry i've got confused with my
slides i just
if could you just go back one sorry
thank you
um the hedge on the boundary with the
neighbouring properties
partially hides the trees and as
mentioned above this hedge is not
covered by the tpo
and is not part of this application if
you go to the next one please
thank you the trees in this location
have high public immunity value and make
a positive contribution to the character
of this part of anchorbold road
next slide please
the trees were surveyed by the applicant
and the area
as a whole was classed as category c
unsuitable for retention
it is therefore part of the landscaping
plan for the site to remove these trees
and replace them next slide please
the awa tree survey has backed up the
recommendations of the applicant survey
whilst acknowledging the tree's immunity
value they say that most trees are in
poor condition
and decline and they all have limited
future prospects and limited long-term
value
and you can see from this slide that
there's a lot of dead
wood in those trees next slide please
the awa survey is published on the
council's website and the main findings
included in the report for this meeting
but in summary the awa survey found that
27 of the trees are in particularly poor
condition
with moderate to major die back in their
crowns significant deadwood and numerous
sufficient
new sorry numerous significant snapped
branches
nine of these trees appear to have had
their main stems
uh snapped out completely leaving a
large proportion of their crowns absent
next slide please
six trees were in slightly better
condition than the other trees
but these also have minor die back minor
dead wood and minor snap outs in their
crown
11 trees were found to have bark wounds
cavities and decays to their stems
and two had evidence of fungal infection
and three
also have included bark unions to their
main stems which are more prone to
failure
most of the trees are leaning with only
five being vertical uh tree trees twelve
i'm sorry twelve are leaning slightly
whilst uh sixteen
are leaning significantly next slide
please
officers recognize that in the short
term there will be an impact on immunity
and biodiversity during the works to
remove the trees
and the period during which the
replacements are reaching maturity
impacts on biodiversity can be
ameliorated by the work being carried
out during the winter when birds are not
nesting
and the condition can be imposed to
ensure that the trees are replaced in
the next planting season after felling
further the proposed mix of long lived
native species
should in the long term provide a more
diverse and long-lived variety of
habitat
which in turn should be more supportive
of biodiversity and will have a greater
immunity value than the present single
species situation
the next few slides just give you more
of a feel of the condition and impact of
the trees
so that's taken from anchor bold road
again from inside the site
and i think there's one more and that's
inside the site as well
um the applicants have um yeah
yeah sorry the applicants have replaced
were proposed replacing the poplars with
14 trees
of a mixture of long-lived native
species including three-filled maple two
oak two small leaved lime
and then some shorter live species
that's two aspen and five birch
these will be located within the garden
boundaries of plots a36
a42 of the development and due to their
species mix will make a long-term
positive contribution to the
biodiversity and amenity of the area
these replacement trees will be
protected under the area tpo
and their management will be included in
the landscaping plan for the site
if this application is approved the
applicants will have to submit
a section 73 application to vary
condition 6 landscaping
to incorporate the new scheme condition
7 of the 2018 permission to develop the
site
requires any trees which within a period
of five years from the completion of the
development die
are removed or become seriously damaged
or diseased shall be replaced in the
next planting season
and these trees would be protected as
part of that
whilst it is recognized that the number
of replacement specimens
is considerably fewer than the 34
poplars they will replace
the choice of species in particular the
maple and oak
will will grow to be shorter in height
but wider in canopy than poplars
they are also of species which are
considerably longer lived
it is therefore office's opinion that
the proposed replacements
suitably protected will in time
contribute positively to the immunity
and biodiversity of the area
in making their recommendation to
members offices have considered
the existing and future impact on
immunity of the poplars which
whilst contributing positive are in a
poor state of health
and we have weighed this against the
immediate impact of felling and the
long-term future impact of replacement
trees on the immunity of the area
as a consequence of the declining
condition of the trees and the
suitability of the proposed replacement
officers are recommending that the
short-term impact
on amenity and biodiversity is
outweighed by the long-term future
positive impact on both immunity and
biodiversity
and recommend that the application to
fill these populace be approved
thank you chair
i'm so sorry to interrupt you chair um
i can't hear you very well is that the
same for all members
yes members are nodding chair and
may you try that again with your
microphone slightly closer
no i think i'm going to get some
technical assistance into if you could
if you could kindly speak as close to
your microphone as possible i'm going to
send some assistance
how's that much better
okay we'll carry on with this as best we
can
so thank you um alice i'm going to
invite the speakers to speak and as the
clerk has already explained
they will each have three minutes to get
over their points they will be in front
when 30 seconds remain as members you
can ask them to clarify any matters that
have been raised
but remember your question should only
relate to the points which have
already been made if the technology
fails us we have asked them to send us
in advance a written statement of their
comments
those that we have received have been
included in the agenda supplement
and i know counselorship and yours was
the late request
so uh i'll set last of the
put it over to you to start your three
minutes
thank you chair and apologies that it
was a bit last minute here we are
um this application has just been
duff from the get-go to be honest
because in the first application that
went in
the assessment said five trees and it
needed to come out
the second assessment said 41 or
whatever it was
and now this one's saying that the 41
trees don't even exist
now what's happened to the other trees
because i don't believe that just
that seven have died in space of you
know whatever it's been
four months i think that that needs to
actually look at in its own right the
other thing for me is that
there's obviously the immunity value of
the trees there themselves they act as a
natural screening from the houses that
are living next to it
a one and a half meter two meter high
hedgerow
from them properties that are elevated
next to it anyway is not going to be
enough alone
those trees provide adequate screening
as things stand
now the other the other thing and i
believe it's the major ritual and we say
it all the time
it's flooding now i don't know if
anyone's been down at that site
recently but you may have seen in the in
the press recently actually that the
residents are being flooded all along
that southern boundary
including where we're talking about
these trees they are actually being
flooded when it rains right now
and i don't think it's fair on them that
an application like this is approved
but for those trees to be pulled out
especially when they scrape the whole
site they've scraped all the topsoil off
the whole site
it's just going to cause additional
problems from those residents down there
so i don't think would puncture so i
can't support the application now as it
stands
if it was going to be approved the trees
that are replacing it
need to be done as soon as possible
after the trees are taken out they
should only be taken out
once the drainage just the full drainage
system for the site has been installed
which is currently working on now anyway
but that's the only part of it they need
to do the whole site so it's actually
draining water off the site as it should
go onto the southern
onto the eastern side of angkor ball
road rather than how it is now
where to be honest the developers seem
to be making it because they go a lot
they really are causing havoc for
residents around
that southern part of that housing
development now obviously we can't do
anything about the houses we're talking
about the trees
we all know trees act as a natural
sponge
when when water is in a certain area so
i don't see how removing
37 or whatever we've got left now is
going to
all aid that situation it's only going
to make it worse
and i have to be here and argue for the
residents that are down there that are
having damaged course to their houses
you know on a weekly seconds remain
um and and yeah i just think that
this this application needs needs
rejected uh but like i said if
if members felt that it needed to go
ahead it certainly needs to be
conditions on when those trees are
pulled out
when the new ones are put back in making
sure the drainage system that they are
installing is fully complete
before the trees are pulled out because
i can see it causing
problems for many years if it's not done
properly that's time chair
thank you councillor are there any
questions for councillor shipman
no indications chair got off lightly
ross
thank you okay
uh we'll cancel the ship and now being
um removed from the meeting nikki
yes sure i'll leave now
thank you
there's no other speakers for this
application and so
i'm just going to throw the floor open
for any comments
to planning offices councillor elliott
thank you chair yeah it's not very often
i agree with ross but
i have to say uh you know if for me
personally if they're taking
41 trees out they put 41 trees back
you know we we looked at quite strictly
on removing edge rows and removing trees
and i agree with the quite a few things
that
ross had to say particularly with the
natural screening
particularly as the roots are a natural
sponge
uh so removing 40 odd trees and only
putting seven or eight back isn't
where i sit happily with it and again
also with the two meat hedgerow that's
there as a screen
if they're going to remove the trees
then i'd like to see
or ensure that we get a hedgerow back as
well as the same amount of trees
excuse me chair is this the stage now
that you want to um
have members ask questions of the
officers yes
sorry um
i've got a counsellor then councillor
armitage
i've finished chair thank you thank you
councillor liggett uh
i'm afraid i'm in agreement with ross as
well um as
we had the same exactly the same thing
happened to us the building site
several hundred yards from us the minute
they took the top soil off we were
flooded
um they chopped approximately 30 trees
down on there before they took the
topsoil off
and we have been having problems ever
since
even though the supposed flood defenses
have been put in
so i am in complete agreement with him
and i also um
i do research during myself and i
disagree strongly with only needing 14
replacement trees
uh and also the size of those 14
replacement trees
they are very small and there are
specialist firms
i.e hilly hilly as a winchester or even
derwent tree skirt skates that can
transport
and move large trees with a huge root
ball
you know and if we're going to have to
take these trees down i'm sure
the developers can afford to replace
them
with trees of virtually the same size
because it is
possible thank you thank you
william if you've got any questions
comments yeah
uh it was a question to uh the officer
really
uh it was to do with the
why there are some trees there which
appear to be okay uh all right
there may not be a hundred percent and
all the rest of it
but couldn't they be saved
and allowed to thrive or is it something
to do with building regulations
whereby you can't build within i think
50 meters because of roots uh i mean
surely this should have gone into when
the plan was originally done
you've got the houses that you propose
right up to the
up to the side uh i think if that had
been the case
there wouldn't have been a nobody would
have bothered about valenties
but uh building reds say that if you got
popular there
you've got to be dig a trench something
like three meters deep
and a meter wide and fill it with
concrete
so i just look at this and i think as
maybe
would you agree this may be an ulterior
motive here
i think that the application has been
put in because of the
condition of the trees which has been
backed up by the second
um survey that we have as a council have
had done
um so that's what we're looking at as
the reasons that's the reasons that has
been put forward and that's the reasons
that
we've assessed it on
i can just add to that to chair if i may
in response to some of the questions
that have been
put in the consideration for members
this afternoon chair is that the primary
issue
but the only issue as far as i
understand the guidance is that the
impact of the trees on the amenity of
the area is the consideration
and therefore whether the proposal to
remove them is justified having regard
to the reasons and the information put
forward in support of the application
chair that's the
issue for members so members need to
consider the amenity of these trees and
therefore whether the reasons for to
remove them
the replacements proposed is acceptable
in terms of the the issue that
councillor elliot
raised in response to some of the
comments from castle shipment chair
the match about 41 out 41 back or
34 out for 34 back whatever it may be
is addressed by office in the report and
on the
various information that we have shown
that the current situation with the
trees is that they are all
cramped together and that's impacted on
their development and the mental value
that they
offer so the 14 that are put back in is
to
seek to allow sufficient space for those
14 replacement trees to develop into
appropriate and suitably sized species
in terms of the the issue about flooding
we are aware as officers that have been
significant
flooding issues with regard to the site
as i say reiterate
that the issue for members is to assess
the amenity of these trees and what
value they have on the
area whether then their removal and
replacement is acceptable or not
and just finely cho in terms of the
issue that
cancer armitage made regarding building
regulations etc
i i don't know whether that is the case
or not but normally even on
sites where trees are present with
suitable
foundations and suitable standoff
distances development can take place in
close association with trees so
without any evidence to that factor i
think it's
it would be unwise to place significant
weight on that issue that the trees are
being removed for some other ulterior
motive
thank you but councilman hill councillor
reader and then councillor armitage
again
councillor hill thank you chair and i
agree with councillor elliott and
council ligger
i i i see the reason for these trees to
be removed if they're diseased
but i do think if we're looking at
replacements
you don't want just whips that are being
put in
you want substantial trees with
substantial roots
and if the developers got to pay to have
them put in then that's what we should
ask or make
as a condition that you put substantial
trees back in
that are already growing and not
not just whips that can die off because
of anything
at all but i i i'm not against the
proposal if the disease they need to go
but i i i don't think we need to have a
look what seriously what we put in the
place
counselor reader thank you chad
um i think i have to agree with
councillor shipman i think it's very
concerning
that we're thinking about um this amount
of trees being
being lost and i agree with uh what
council eliot's just said with regards
to
to the issues around the flooding and uh
councillor liggett made the point as
well
they are like a natural sponge which so
cut the water
um you know and we've had issues around
clay cross also with trees
when they get removed and flooding that
occurs
uh after that so i i do agree with those
sentiments but
i also have to disagree slightly with
adrian at looking at just the immunity
i think we've also got to consider uh
the the benefit of trees
environmentally as well and yes i get
that there there might be some uh
trees that are showing uh disease
but the the nature of ripping out lots
and lots of trees together
concerns me and you've already indicated
that there's a massive
environmental and biodiverse impact on
this and i would have probably
preferred to see more of a phased
approach
uh to removing those trees and you know
i did have a little chat with
uh a parish councillor um who's quite
experienced in trees much more than i
am um just to get what he thinks around
around these trees um you know and he
made the point to me you know that
canker is not it's not terminal
there are things that can be done so i
think there has to be questions about
how the
uh person that you know is responsible
for the trees how much they've looked
after these trees
so my first question to the officer
would be
under the tpo how much responsibility
has the owner got to
ensure those trees are in in kept in a
fit state and obviously
whatever happens after these what is
going to secure the future of any future
trees that are put in place as well
because
the last thing we would want is for any
trees that are replaced for
them to end up in a similar state to
these trees that you know are not in in
such a good state now
also i think collectively they form a
significant
amount of meaning in terms of screening
for the residents down
there um you know so it would need
comprehensive screening and replanting
to go back in there so i do sort of
agree
uh you know that we need to be looking
at making sure
that the trees are replaced and replaced
with
trees that are mature enough to provide
that stable and that screening that the
the
you know it's not going to be a tree
that's going to be
you know broken or you know and it needs
to be monitored
as well um i think we also need to
um think about what council armitage was
saying with regards to
the roots of the trees and again when i
was sort of trying to get some
information about trees because i'm not
a
tree expert by any means of the world
but he was saying
you know sometimes the reason why
developers might need
the removal of popular trees is
um generally a shallow root would spread
three times the height of the trees
therefore if the trees were a height of
about 150 feet
then a root protection area would be
needed of about 450 feet
so there's going to be issues around
that so i would have questions
around you know what what are the
reasons that we really need these trees
pulling out
as they are and i'm not saying chair
that i don't agree that if they're
diseased
we need to be replacing but i think a
more phased approach
and proper you know proper management of
how they're removed
would be better
thank you would you like to come back
with any of those points chair
check and you're here i can hear you but
can you hear me
we can now chair okay thank you off you
go adrian
thank you chair just done on some of
those points um it's been raised by
council's reader and hill chair and the
advice
i've just given to members comes from
the
planning practice guidance note which
gives advice on
what decision makers should take into
account in considering applications for
consent and retreat preservation order
and that's
that the impact of the proposal on the
amenity of the areas the consideration
whether the proposed justified bearing
in mind
the reasons information put forward and
support it and you've heard
alice earlier on and set out in the
report the reasons why
in this case the various pieces of
advice that we've received had
led to the conclusion that the removal
of the trees and their replacement would
be most appropriate
in terms of future protection if you
were minded to grant consent and
require replacement trees as alice has
mentioned because the trees form part of
an area tree preservation or that they
would
achieve protection under that order
further to replacement
regarding the replacements themselves
shows catholic hill mentioned
the consideration always has to be
height over
longetivity because normally when the
larger the trees that go in
are the lower they are lesser longer
they take to
take and therefore develop significant
impacts chair as the smaller trees
generally grow better and more adapted
to their surroundings in this case
and perhaps as some members know the
height of
three to three and a half meters of the
proposed standard trees replaced
is seeking to strike a balance between
those two
elements chair and um
finally just in terms of again the root
protection areas
the council readers made some points on
that channel and were able to contradict
it
i would reiterate that those issues
would normally be addressed through
building regulations in terms of how
suitable foundations for new dwellings
would be
in such proximity to trees such as
poplars as in this case chair but
fundamentally the issue for members to
consider is
the level of amenity of the trees on the
area and whether the reasons put forward
to
support that proposal is overriding
chair
thank you thank you councillor foster
than councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh councillor foster
member for coal aston
um question for mr kirkham if we're
still in questions
um and it follows on from what counselor
hill says and a bit about
a bit uh what you've already explained
uh with regarding
uh the replacement trees um i can see
the heights three to three and a half
meters
the most and the girths which are 10
to 12 centimeters and you've explained i
think in so many words that these are
the optimum
uh size tree uh
because of how quick they'll grow this
size uh
do we have any of the options as regards
uh not as inc
i understand the quantity of trees and
the sort of trees that
uh there are and they won't necessarily
want to replace them with 34 trees
so i can understand that number uh
but when it comes to the size of those
trees do we have any options
uh i take your point about them growing
better if they're that size
but are there other options do other
people
have other planning committees ask for
bigger trees to be put in uh are bigger
trees often planted can they be planted
so do we have any options to plant much
bigger trees
even though they might not grow as well
but people can have the big trees they
want from the start
thanks i'll come back first of all jeff
i may
alice who's perhaps a bit more knowledge
on
this issue than myself may want to add
something at the end but
the options for for members are
first of all you can refuse the
application if you don't feel the
reasons put forward to justify the
removal of the trees is
is sufficient and the trees do offer
level of amenity value you wish to see
retain that's that's the first option
if you're minded to approve the schemes
the removal of all the
proposed trees then the options are for
you to require
more or different replacement trees in
terms of height or
size or species that is and within the
gift of the planning committee chair as
council fosters mentioned
as officers we believe the balance
between
future amenity value and growth and
speed of that growth and adaptivity of
the new trees to the surroundings
that it's seeking despite that balance
we believe as officers but
if members were minded to seek taller
trees then
you can plant as council lights alluded
to earlier chair
there are taller trees than standard
alice may
know the specifics of that but yes you
could seek toiletries
as i say they tend to generally take
um not as well and longer than the
smaller ones but
the whips obviously at only a few um
centimeters high
and are a lot smaller about 10 over time
and but i'm talking years rather than
weeks
[Music]
of future growth over a longer
term period i hope that helps chair is
answering council foster's questions
thank you
councillor armitage then councillor
liggett
yeah thank you very much chair uh it's
really just to point out uh
about planting trees i lived uh for many
years
next door to dolby forests and i used to
follow how the
forestry commission went about planting
trees
uh you don't put single trees in like
that
how they do it they put plenty in
and then after 10 years they thinned
them
uh if you just put an odd tree in
they'll blow over you get wind blow
you have to be careful about thinning in
any case
because you have to be doing it very it
has to be done very carefully
because you can also create a wind
tunnel and you'll get wind blow
just the same if we're talking about
routes
and route protection areas then uh
i think the officers ought to be minded
and not to check building
regulations about building next to
poplars and also
trees and checking the root protection
area
because they obviously don't really
realize
uh the implications when you start
building next to poplars
and this should have been realized when
they uh
approved the plans of these houses which
were right up
next to the poplar trees uh but this was
obviously
an afterthought and that's why i still
maintain
that's why they want these trees
removing there may be some of them which
are diseased
well take some of them out and replace
them
but what's the point having a tpo if you
wanted to fell trees left right and
center
let's have them replaced put twice as
many in if need be
and then thin you thin them out you put
things like
oaks in and okay live for 300 years
who's going to look after where's the
management team going to be in 300 years
there may not be about if it's a limited
company in three years let alone
for 300 and these are my worries
and i think it's an ill device plan this
wrong variety of trees and you know
just destroying them because of
basically because of the route
it's not so much damage it's to do with
the rules
and building regulations
okay okay if i may um if i may come in
regarding that the points that
um council amateurs have said regarding
the the motive
i think you need to disregard that to be
honest i think
um it's that may well be the case
however you need to consider the um
the application on the on the um
on the basis of uh the reason for the
application to remove the trees you
cannot
decide yourself that the the motive for
the removal of the trees is anything
other than the immunity of the area
and it would be very dangerous for you
to uh make a decision
uh on on your uh
belief that it the motive is anything
other than the immunity of the area
um also whilst um whilst i'm talking i
think it may be worth
um pointing out to members that if
you don't approve this application and
eventually
um that the tree um is considered to be
dead or or dangerous then the applicants
can remove those
whatever tree is dead or dangerous uh
without any uh need to apply for
permission from the
from the local authority so um there's a
risk that if
if he does that uh we can't we cannot
then require them to put a replacement
tree
where he he's removed a a dead or a
dangerous tree
thank you james councillor liggett yeah
just getting back to the size of trees
if we took
in bare-rooted trees then fair enough
three meters
but i'm not talking about their rooted
i'm talking about
property with a proper root ball that
has been
transformed by a proper company
and i mean you've only got to look at
chelsea and we've all seen
large trees in those gardens that are
moved several times
um and they do survive if they've got a
decent root ball and they will survive
so that's that's all i want to make the
comment on thank you
okay are there any more questions for
the offices
no okay
right perhaps we'll open the floor for
proper debate now we seem to have
covered most of it
has anyone got anything further they'd
like to add
councillor foster councillor parts
uh yeah um uh
for myself i was when this came last
time to
uh the planning committee i took the
word of
uh our parks officers that went around
and assessed these trees
and i could see the point in the trees
uh being taken down
and also with them being replaced by uh
by
appropriately appropriate replacements
so i could see that from the start
uh for me so so last time
uh that was my position uh the last time
we knocked it back
um because we were all happy here to go
away and
spend money or get the council to spend
money on
a further report because we doubted the
officers uh recommendations last time
no not the planning officers but the uh
the officers that went to see the trees
and gave the report
we've since had uh a report which more
or less confirms
more or less confirms the same uh by awa
um
i'm not sure if we paid for that or the
applicants paid for that so uh that i
don't know
um so now i feel like twice now i've
been told that these trees
need cutting down there are replacements
and
i've questioned the size of the
replacements and we've had a
recommendation there as well
now unlike other people on this
committee i'm definitely no expert in
trees but i'm happy to trust the
the opinions that i've been given uh
i've been giving them twice now
and lastly jim fields ends point uh
about the applicant being able to cut
the trees down anyway without being
required to replace them
there's now two reports here in front of
the planning committee and both of those
say that this these treaties are
diseased
i need to be cut down if i were the
applicant
uh i'd be thinking well i can just cut
these trees down now
so me we might want these trees to stay
up but
what's to stop this person this this
applicant cutting these trees down now
uh so for me i'm it's clear uh
it's clear as dear to me on this one i
don't find this one hard at all i know
we're not proposing any emotions at the
minute but
you know i'm in favor of uh following uh
recommendations
from the officer um yeah it's as clear
as that
thank you council potts then councillor
powell and councillor cooper
oh thank you chair um first of all i'm i
was
wasn't at the meeting where this um came
i think it was it's september time so
this one is i'm coming
to it new but um i'm beginning to wonder
why we've
um why we ask for specialist reports if
we're going to totally disregard
um what they say in much the same
veiners
council of foster there i think if we do
nothing
um it's clear both reports have said
that many
most of the trees are coming to the end
of their natural life if we do nothing
we'll end up without any trees there at
all
um the only i mean i'm happy
and when a proposal is made i will vote
for officer recommendation on this
the only thing i would say is i think
when um
when the officer read a report out she
said that six of the trees
were in reasonable condition so i would
put an amendment in there to see if we
could
actually save those six trees um
but in terms of officer recommendation
um
yeah that's what i will be supporting
today thank you chair
thank you council pal
thank you chair um
the last time that we looked at this we
cut it
out on one of our officers who came in
for a certain degree of criticism
which i thought was very disappointing
um
we've now had an independent report
which we called for
and it has confirmed largely what that
original officer said
um i think we should apologize for that
officer to be honest
but that's just an aside and that's how
i feel about it
um as far as this is concerned it seems
quite simple to me
and we asked for another opinion we've
got it
what is the point as councillor foster
says of asking experts for an opinion
and then saying
we know better than them because that's
really what we're doing
and we're all you know some people are
professing i don't know
anything about trees but and then giving
a view
i think we should take the independent
uh
recommendation on the independent report
at face value
um and i would rather see a managed
tree system here rather than
uh one where maybe the odd one will be
cut down
by the developer as of when he or she
thinks fit
we need a proper management plan and
that's what we get
if we vote for the officer's
recommendation which i will be doing
thank you chair thank you councillor
cooper
yeah sorry thank you cheer i have to say
i agree totally with um
councillors potts foster and powell um
i'd much rather see
this as a managed state and and trees
that are going to
survive and look well for many years to
come the only thing i would question is
some
something of the size of them whether we
could look at um
adding some slightly larger trees to
that
and whether that's something um that
could be conditioned
but other than that i i also will be
supporting this
um this motion
counselor foster uh thank you chair uh
yeah um
as well as jim fields point about uh the
applicant being able to cut the trees
down anyway and
not replace them this can also and it's
not always a consideration of mine not
always
this could easily go to appeal uh it
could
cost in the council money when we've not
followed these recommendations by
officers
and two uh reports one by our own tree
surgeons
and another one which is uh an
independent one which we've requested so
this
could quite easily uh be overturned um
uh so for me um i don't want to sound
too challenging when i say this
but if if if we look at those because
i'm a big fan of trees and i'm a big fan
of planting them and
anybody that knows me knows that what
i've been involved with before
but if you look at those people that are
minded to
not grant this application to fill those
trees on what grounds
what grounds do we have out there what
policies
have we got out there that can actually
justifiably
uh stop this if you're thinking of
putting a motion
to stop this going ahead what you know
what policies
you know you might want the trees to be
there it might be flooding you know
we've got to have some sort of policy
there
uh and we've got to follow policy at the
end of the day um
if there's something there somebody can
persuade me other than what i've heard
so far from officers and experts if
there's
if there's something in our local
planner uh adopted one or uh
or the next local plan if there's
something there which says that you know
we can knock this bike i'd be happy to
hear it and listen
okay thank you councillor liggett
council earlier councillor armitage
thank you uh i'm not disagreeing with
officer recommendations what i am
disagreeing with
is the amount that's being replanted and
the size
if the amount can be upped because of
natural natural diet which you will get
and if we could have a few large trees
so there's still that amenity there and
the
water drinking capabilities of a larger
tree
thank you thank you councillor elliot
thank you chair chair i completely agree
with most of the things i've heard and i
i do
uh i do agree with councillor foster
when i when i first put in about the you
know
that i agreed with ross on the on the
use of the roots for sucking up the
water
and so on anchor bold road has always
always been a flood risk area on the
other side of the road anyway
so taking trees out to me makes no sense
um however i stick by what i said about
i'd like to see the same amount put back
but i will quite happily move officer
recommendation but with the conditions
that we do get more trees back and i
also agree that we've had two reports
and both of those reports
are absolutely right what's the point in
taking a report and then ignoring the
advice from an expert
the thing that that i don't quite get is
if some
are seriously diseased i have no issue
with them taking them out
if they're a safety risk or a hazard to
either a building or the public i have
no
no no problem at all taking those out
but when i heard
originally that some of these were just
minor
and some had bark indentations
as an as a non-expert yeah i questioned
why we're taking those out that
aren't seriously diseased or or with
bark indentations to them
but i will happily move recommendation
with the conditions that we get more
trees by
thank you councillor armitage then
councillor hill
uh i agree with the council eliot
we do need more treason uh
you can't leave so many of these
big tall trees because you'll get wind
blow and they're going to come down
it's first scale uh because
the trees in the forest sort of shield
each other
you leave one standing like that and it
won't last 10 minutes as soon as you get
a first
gale it'll come down so you're going to
do a clear fell and then
plant and plant enough trees to take
uh at this 14 well no i i can't agree
with that
we want more trees uh and let's
uh put that like with like as regards
numbers
and put some big decent trees in to
alleviate the
flooding problems and on those
conditions
i will go with our officers
recommendation
now come back because when's appropriate
please
okay i think it's this mike's going mad
councillor hill
yeah thank you chair uh i i agree with
other speakers that
with cancer elliott and council foster i
have no concerns about
voting yes for this but i am concerned
about the size of the trees
and how many and i'd just like to ask as
an
aside what about the hedge
is the hedge uh ancient edge
because if it is there's a law against
touching it
you know and i just wonder whether
that's been i don't want to throw cat
amongst pigeons
i'm quite willing to vote for for
officers recommendations this but with
the conditions that's been stated
about how many trees and the size of
them
thank you adrian
just come back just one or two points
there first of all
to avoid any doubt the survey that was
done by awa was that the
request and direction of the council
that wasn't done
any direction of the applicant so it was
managed by ourselves and paid for by the
council as well
just in terms of the six trees that have
been mentioned that
are slightly better than the others
they're the ones
i believe that are mentioned at the top
of page 21 but even those trees
they're only in slightly better
condition and they also
according to awa have minor diet money
date would minus step out so
they're not anywhere near perfect just
in terms of
a replacement chair i fully understand
the comments that members are making and
condition two
as it as proposed would require the
replacement scheme as per
the information in your packs if you
were minded to approve the scheme
chair subject to amendments that in
terms of numbers and
size as in the discussion then that
could be
amended to require a scheme to be
submitted to
and approved by the council but it would
be my view
that in view of the current state of the
trees that are
in that area that it would be
inappropriate to require
41 or even 34 replacements but if
members
were otherwise minded to support the
recommendation
then that condition could be altered to
require a scheme
that may prove closer to members wishes
than the one that's
been submitted and just finally channel
the issue of the hedge
the proposal is only seeking to
do works to the trees there's no
intention to
have any impact on the hedge uh as
councillor hill
notes and in circumstances hedges do
retain protection although
where they form boundary to residential
property they don't have that protection
but currently there's no proposals
to alter the hedge and again subject to
anything alice may say
i am of the uh i am of the
uh view that that hedge is to be
retained as part of the wider
landscaping scheme for the side
so there's no intention for that hedge
to be removed certainly not as part of
this application but i believe it would
be retained in any case
thank you chair thank you
oh sorry if i'm if i may i did i did
move recommendation now adrian's come up
with that amendment
for the planting i'll quite happily move
it sorry
as i understood at this stage council
reality you're indicating that
that's what you would do when the chair
had opened up the floor to motions so
before committee just an indication that
people will move motions along those
lines
right i thought i'd made the motion
providing with the amendments
are you comfortable with that chair
though at the moment uh the floor is yet
to be opened up for motions
yeah thank you okay thank you what's the
fostering council of parts with
the asked to come in uh yeah uh thanks
chair
i think as this came he came to us
before in september
i think uh while we've been uh knocking
this backwards and forwards we've
already missed one growing season
so i think that's probably worth bearing
in mind uh when we're making decisions
about
when we want these trees planted we've
already done that um
also um when it comes to us deciding
what trees we want i think we're all
gonna be careful because i don't know
much about trees i'm not gonna know how
many trees
we want to put down on this list you
know i'm looking at that table from
field maple to
uh aspen to i know what an oak looks
like but i don't know the difference
between uh
a field maple and a lime somebody might
i don't know how many more trees we're
going to request and of what type
it's all a bit uh that's why i'm happy
to listen to people that know about
trees
and put a tree plant forward if there's
anybody here knows enough
to actually increase one of these trees
or another tree and where to put them
you know i'm happy to follow that but i
think that's a bit difficult
councillor parts thank you chair
yeah my point was about the suggestion
of putting in extra trees
um are you gonna squash them in the same
area length that the trees are occupying
at the moment or you were planning to
increase
the length of the tree line because
different species of trees have
different growing requirements they go
at different rates to different heights
they have different
canopy widths so if we're talking we've
already been we've already had the
officers explained
that um that the type of trees
and the number of trees is designed to
give them
the maximum and best starting in life
and to ensure the long-term
prosperity so when we're talking about
extra trees
can we just have some clarification as
to whether we're going to plant
more in that same length or whether
you're suggesting that that tree line
be somehow extended because if we're
going to cram them all in
surely they're not like they're going to
be overgrown they're going to be a
tangled mess
and we're probably going to end up with
diseased trees and in a few years to
come
maybe we'll be having this conversation
again so if somebody could just clarify
that proposal for me please
thank you alice and then councillor
powell
um just to let you know chair um
under the regulations for tree
preservation orders
for areas uh we cannot condition
trees to be planted outside of the
existing area
so that's that about 100 meter by 20
meter strip that i showed you on the
plan
uh we can't condition any trees outside
of that
um in this in this situation
just at one point to that chair if i may
um
the comments that members will receive
first i've said last september and now
in
in
the current report on page 13 members
i'm sure will have noted that parks
officers
have commented on the proposed
replacement scheme and
have given the view that the space
afforded to the trees as councilor potts
has just mentioned
that would allow them to establish
naturally and when they become mature
will potentially cause less problems
nearby properties in any case so
the parks officers have already
suggested that the submitted scheme for
replacement is
is appropriate so members may wish to
bear that in mind in their
considerations thank you thank you
councillor pal and then i will open the
floor because i think we've done this to
death
yeah so do i i think i'll go back to my
original point about
expertise um and what just adrian has
just said has sort of coalesced it as
far as i'm concerned
what's the point of having experts
what's the point of asking their opinion
and then
us let's face it as amateurs
um going against them i i would
certainly support the officer's
recommendation
if there is a rider to that that
the officer is delegated to talk again
to the developer
perhaps um about um
a few more trees but not many um i think
that might be a way out of our impasse
thank you thank you i am going to open
it promotions now and i believe council
already that you put one forward
we'll start with you i did chair i'm
quite happy to move it
and i i agree with council powell as
well
uh if we can leave that with adrian to
amend it to get some more trees planted
in there
and we're not we're not talking about
outs planting outside the
100 meters quite happy to go with that
anyway that affords us the screen that's
already
mature and there okay have our secondary
yeah i'll second it thank you councillor
pal
so the motion there venture is to move
officer recommendations
subject to further second i believe
chair yeah yeah so move officer
recommendations
uh subject to further discussions about
the planning manager
uh with the developer in terms of the
possible addition of some
more trees if that were
accepted by members chair that would
require a slight amendment to condition
to
so not accepting the current proposals
for
replacement books requiring that to be
submitted and approved by ourselves
subsequent to any decision although
bearing in mind the point that council
fosters made that would
and inevitably lead to
some delay in the potential replanting
probably until the next planting season
okay all right
are you happy with that counselor
earlier council armitage
well yes
if we want numbers could we say 23s
it's just six extra
i think chair um specifying numbers
without knowing species and details is
is is um doesn't leave officers a great
deal of
consideration or
remember to decide but my recommendation
would be to require a suitable scheme of
replacement and replanting
and we'll have officers speak to the
developer and colleagues as to whether
we can get more than 14 and it may
actually be a matter of getting some of
the other species that
the parks officers talked about some of
the smaller species hawthorne perhaps
mentioned in their comments chair i'm
happy with that
my recommendation would not be to
specify a number
thank you councillor it's okay with that
are you okay with that counselor
armitage
yeah okay so just to be clear chair
that's uh approve
of his recommendations uh but with the
requirement that a suitable uh scheme of
replacement and replanting
should be agreed yes
can we have a vote on that please
if you chair i'll conduct the vote by
roll call if you can clearly say
for against or abstain on the proposals
put
counselor armitage or counselor cooper
four council elliot four
council foster
four castle hill four
casa liggett or casa potts
or casa powell or
casarida or caster roust
or
thank you all very much that's carried
thank you can move on to the next
application
which i believe is the one for holy
moore's side so that's
ned forward 20 4 0 1
5 1 4 fl
and i believe you're the case officer
agent
i'll introduce to the chair if i may and
sue is in the
room with us if um clarification needs
specific points and after i've
introduced the application
which i'll go through the slides as as
normal
and in this instance chair the
application seeks to retain a partially
constructed agricultural building at
holy moore side
it measures approximately 12 meters by
12 meters there's an overall height
weaves of four meters
it's intended to construct the building
as a replacement for existing chicken
sheds which we'll see on the photographs
in a second
permission has been granted chair in
2020 for a building on the site
the building the subject of this
application is rotated 90 degrees to
that approved
there's four roof lights it's very
slightly further south than the one that
has been approved
back in 2020 for the wise chair it's
exactly the same as that already
permitted
which establishes the fallback position
which is a factor material to your
decision this afternoon
at yesterday's site visit chair it was
queried why room flights were not
proposed in the
as approved structure officers chair
don't have
exact information on why that change is
taking place but we are advised now that
roof lights are required
for animal welfare reasons the site
chairs located in the greenbelt where
agricultural buildings are
acceptable and appropriate development
the reasons set out in the report share
the design of the building is considered
to be acceptable
impact on the landscape is also
considered acceptable and no important
views are set out in the neighborhood
plan
be damaged or affected the building
chair is over 42 meters to the boundary
with the nearest residential property
and even further from the dwellings
themselves in the opinion of officers
this will ensure no unacceptable impact
is called to neighboring amenities
there aren't any technical reasons chair
to refuse the application hence the
officer recommendation for approval and
if i can just ask
nikki now to run through the
presentation
from members thanks nikki
the application site chair outlined in
the
lighter color you can just see an
existing building within that area
that's roughly where the proposed
building would be located if you just
move on mickey please
this application this slideshare shows
the proposed building in
in red and black at the center of the
red lined area
and the approximate position of the four
chicken sheds that would be removed
from the site are shown hatched and you
can see those
on the drawing chair the measurements
also show that the building is
say just in excess of 42 meters from the
boundary with the residential property
to the south
and approximately 30 meters from the
track leading to the farm
to the west thanks nikki
just showing the details as i said
building four meters
to eaves and just in excess of 12 meters
by 12 meters square in terms of
floor area you can see the full roof
lights in profile there
thanks nikki and
another elevations chair
thank you this is one of the
um photographs that's referred to in the
opposite committee report chair showing
the existing situation
in regards to the removal of the eggs
from one of the sheds
thanks nikki and now
chair the the application building is
that on the very left of this
photograph and in the foreground on the
right
you can see one of the existing sheds
that would be
removed from the site should the
building gain approval and be occupied
just in the far distance the the white
house with the grey roof
is the nearest residential property and
as i say the distance from the building
to the hedges just in excess of 42
meters
and that's members to bear that in mind
as we get to the end of this
element of the presentation because as
requested yesterday we have included in
the presentation photographs
submitting representations from that
property
which meant for me to assess in their
deliberations but
as i say the distance from the building
to that hedge is 42 meters just in
excess of 42 meters then further
to the property itself thanks nikki
this is the building from closer to the
farm complex buildings
and again you can see the property in
the background the white property the
nearest residential property
and just in the middle left of the
photograph
the tree line the hedge line there is
the
location of the public footpath that's
referred to and we'll see again
and towards the end some photographs
take me the other direction from that
footpath
thanks nikki and this is taken from
closer to the main
chesterfield to basler road close to the
access into the site so the main farm
buildings are off to the left
and in the foreground two of the
buildings that would be removed
and the application building in the
center of the photograph
thanks nikki and this is a simple
photograph were taken from the access
track to the farms this is taken from
the
west looking at the application building
thank you
and similarly again you can see existing
buildings in the
foreground application building center
left
thank you this is a photograph taken
from the
footpath as i've mentioned those
photographs now as submitted in
representations
which were submitted in our position to
the application with the application
building
is clear there in the center of the
photograph
the access track to the farm where we
just seen some other photographs is
located along the tree line in the
beyond the building
thanks nikki
this is taken from residential property
to the
um south and east
thank you and then
jared as members requested yesterday
these the photographs submitted
representation from the
nearest property that's the white
property i've made reference to on one
or two occasions and that's the
structure being constructed you can see
the chicken sheds
in the middle distance just this side of
the
metal structure that's going going up
thank you nikki and again
share and similarly thank you
and this again is now got a roof on and
you can see the hedge line in the near
distance
is the boundary of that residential
property so from that boundary
to the building is the 42 meters i keep
on referring to
famous nikki and then finally chair just
again the final slide that's been
submitted in representation from the
opposition the opponents of the
application chair
that's all in the presentation thank you
oh can you hear me now yes jerry just
can't okay thank you
are there any questions for
clarification at this point
just one and then we're going to move on
to the speaker's counselor foster
yeah a question for mr kirkham it's just
a bit of clarity
between uh 7.1
where it says in the neighborhood plan
um
[Music]
uh it echoes national policy relating to
the green belt where development will
only be permitted
in very special circumstances unless it
is considered
not appropriate as an adequate
agricultural building the development is
not appropriate development in the green
belt
and yet we've got an 8.1 uh it's not
inappropriate development in the
greenbelt and planning
policies are generally supportive of
justified agricultural development in
the countryside it's a working farm
uh so just a bit of clarity between
those two positions this 7.1 and the 8.1
they just look a little bit uh
another two different plans one's uh
uh ones that one's our own local plan
and one's the neighbor
plan but if you could just uh explain
the difference between those please
just point to clarity from the cast of
foster chair first of all up to
paragraph 7.1
it states as an agricultural building
development is not inappropriate
development
in the green belt and i think that
mirrors
what council foster said later on
not sure i'm i'm following the element
of clarity that's needed
i apologize it's me reading not not
inappropriate and all the rest of it so
i apologize
thank you i'm pleased about that
got one speaker and that's the agents
that's charlotte stanton
and i'll remind you that they've got
three minutes to give their presentation
hello charlotte hi there can everyone
hear me
yes thank you
adam's happy hens is a local free-range
egg
business with a popular farm shop that
has been important for many people
during lockdown
adam is the third generation of his
family working the farm
and he's passionate about its future in
august last year the council granted
planning permission for a chicken shed
due to a mix-up the building does not
match exactly with the approved plans
adam apologized and stopped work
there are three differences between the
two schemes
the building has its ridgeline east-west
instead of north-south
four translucent roof panels have been
added for natural light
which the architect missed off the
original plans by mistake
the building is in a slightly different
position
but the building is the same size as the
one approved last year
we ask you to focus your decision please
on whether the three differences would
result in any greater impact than the
approved building
the objections are not about the changes
but about the building being there at
all
the main objective bought their house
after the original planning permission
was approved
the building is almost 43 metres from
the neighbour's garden
and is only visible because the
applicant kindly cut the hedges at the
roof
at the neighbor's request the photos
you've seen
are zoomed in the building is square
so changing the orientation of the roof
has not changed the length of the
building as viewed from the neighbors
instead it has changed what would have
been a gable end to a sloping roof
as you know private views are not a
material consideration
the chicken shed will replace four
wooden sheds two of these
are nearer to the neighbors the existing
sheds are old and do not have sufficient
height to allow good air flow or to
allow a trap tractor in for cleaning out
the timber buildings increase the
chances of red mags
they are a fire risk their outside water
pipes keep freezing
and they need cleaning out more often
making it very muddy
the mud around the four buildings and
their old design is making egg
collection
feeding and caring for the chickens
difficult and is churning up the whole
field
because of bird flu regulations all
birds must currently be kept inside
and adam is very keen to get them in the
new building to significantly improve
their
air quality and give them a bit more
space there are significant operational
and animal welfare reasons for needing
the new building
your planning policies fully support an
essential agricultural building
as you know this is a working landscape
30 seconds remain
the building has no greater impact than
the one already
approved you could refuse the mission
today and adam would have to spend money
turning the building 90 degrees
but what would this achieve we ask you
please to support this hard-working
local farmer
to complete the building and give his
hens the best possible quality of life
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no vote counselor elliott
sorry chad it wouldn't unmute for me
technology chair i just did want to ask
charlotte what and i agree i don't think
it's going to make a great deal of
difference spinning it around and
costing
money for that i just wanted to ask what
the original roof height was not not to
the eaves because i know that's four
meters
has it changed much in the roof height
the ridge height from the original
application no uh
the ridge height has not changed and the
eaves height has not changed
the actual size of the building itself
has not changed at all it's just changed
in orientation yeah well i know you said
it was just a little bit
off where it was developed supposed to
be developed on
and i think that's only a couple of
meters after reading over all the bump
its thanks y'all that's right thank you
thank you any other questions
no thank you charlotte for that thank
you
thank you i'll open the floor for debate
or no first are there any questions to
the actual planning officer
no okay the floor is open for debate
and i've got to say i if you followed
the
application on the website i've never
seen so many people in support of this i
think it's a great idea
but there we go anybody any comment
yeah can i come in sure
yeah i think it's uh a well-designed
building
uh we've passed it before uh when it was
uh
in its original place uh they just
uh well i don't really know what went
wrong uh
a mistake on the part of the builder uh
and as far as animal welfare yeah you've
got to have
a tall building to get the airflow uh
i presume it's a deep litter uh shed
and as a result you do get quite a lot
of uh
ammonia and what have you been uh
created
and i myself you know i would go with
officers recommendation but you're not
ready for that yet are you
not yet another comment
any other comment counselor parts just a
quick one and i've probably missed the
the opportunity to um to ask it to the
appropriate person
but i just wondered if um there will be
any more chickens kept in that shed or
if it is just to house the ones that the
existing
four smaller sheds um house
i don't know yeah yeah sadly i don't
um i don't know either chair i'm afraid
i don't know whether sue is able to
to advise but my understanding was it
was to accommodate
existing chickens in a more appropriate
environment but sue will be able to
confirm that
yes chair i did ask the question when we
were dealing with the application
there's no intention to intensify the
use
it's simply for the existing chickens
thank you councillor armagedd yeah
uh as uh probably uh one of the only
qualified people to speak on this
defra have specifications for
what you can keep and how many square
meters per bird and this sort of thing
and no doubt uh their
people will come along and inspect in
the same way that
you know we get environmental health in
this cut in
our profession but they have strict
uh guidelines and people have to adhere
to them
thank you any other comment
no okay shall we move for a motion has
anyone got a motion to put forward
yes i'll put one forward i propose that
we go along with the
officer's recommendation and that we
approve this
and i'll second that chair thank you
i will take a vote on it thank you nikki
chair as before um you're voting uh for
against or abstain if you could clearly
indicate when i call your name
cancer armitage four council cooper
four council elliot four
casa foster four
councillor hill cancer ligate
or cancer pots
for casa powell oh
cancer reader or has a rouse
or anti-cancer rough
oh that's unanimous chair thank you
we can move on to application number
three
which is ned forward slash
twenty four slash zero zero nine seven
nine forward slash fl change of use
of a stable block and tractor store
are this is this the one you're leading
with yes i'm leading on this one chair
thank you and this application as you
just pointed out
seeks to convert a form where stable
building and attractor store
along with creating a link extension to
form a single dwelling
the stable chair was granted planning is
sent in 2005 whilst the tractor store
obtained consent in 2016 to support the
nearby
peak edge hotel the site chair is
located in the countryside with clear
views of the site from the local highway
and public footpath networks and we'll
see some photographs of that in a second
both buildings chair currently exhibit a
simple design
and to deliver the conversion it's
proposed to reface the buildings in
stone and timber cladding
and introduce in the opinion of officers
significant in character changing
openings
development plan policies chair both
local and neighbourhood planners do
allow for the conversion of buildings
which subject to them being capable of
conversion without major alteration
adaptation and reconstruction
and without an unacceptable impact on
the area
obviously there are offices are of the
view chair that the extent of change
proposed
along with significant number of new and
altered openings
and major alterations and so the
proposal not be compliant
with your policies set out in the
development plan
the building's chair are currently
simple in appearance and we'll see that
in the photographs in a second
and it's considered that the changes for
both would dilute their simple form and
character
and so on it unacceptably impacted the
area
in addition share the large amount of
glazing is likely to introduce
significant levels of light in country
to policy ap 19 of the neighborhood plan
regarding dark skies couple to this
chair and i sit out in the report is the
impact of the
extensive garden that would be formed
and be associated with any new dwelling
of the impact this would have on the
rural carriage of the area
in conclusion share offices consider the
level of change proposed the buildings
the area generally is unacceptable
contrary to the policies of your
development plan
and hence the recommendation to refuse
the application
thanks nikki
just have the first slide please the
application site chair is
the orange area with the access onto the
chesterfield matlock road which is the
road that runs along the
right side of the slide the road to the
north of the top of the slide the north
is the road that then
follows on to two dales and daley dale
the
peak edge hotel complex is the area the
left of the photograph
thanks nikki
the application sidechair outlined in
red with the applicants or the land
holdings in blue
as i've just said the access to the
chesterfield matlock road
you're able to see that along the top
edge of the access track
and the application site and then
towards peak hotel
is a problem footpath thanks nikki
the size that it stands to is occupied
by the two buildings with an area of
hard standing again we'll see
that in a second in the photographs the
application
site and it's part of what half of that
area that's in grey there with the lower
half
and presumably retaining its uses as
meadow
generally grassed area thanks nikki
the application chair contains the
buildings but adds that
link linking the two buildings together
that's a glaze link and we'll see that
on the
drawings at the next slide thanks nikki
this is the existing buildings
the two buildings the stables which is
the
lower of the two and the tractor shed
which is the larger of the two
just to point out to members as we go
into the next slide you'll be able to
see the difference between the openings
in
this in the structures as they are at
the moment and those that post if you
just go back
just just one
the you'll be able to see that there's
the large opening in the tractor
shed and the openings on the stable
and then there's a single opening on the
rear elevation of the stable
at the top of the slide and then you can
just go on one now
you can see that the building for
example the
track shed has floor to top of apex of
roof glazed openings it's got
new openings in the elevations or other
than the rear elevation
and the building would be re-clad rather
than the block work and sheeting stands
at the moment with the
stone and the timber cladding as you can
see on the the drawing
so as we go through the slides just if
you can bear in mind the
level of openings that are proposing
particularly the glazing that's proposed
on
this elevation that's facing us now and
in this
slide the application buildings are at
the center right
of the photograph there's the larger
tractor
store which is the green upper area
which is the sheeting and then the
stable building to its left
the building on the far left is the peak
hotel
complex and just beyond the application
site you can just see the cars that are
traveling along the
the dali road this photograph is taken
from
berlin lane which is to the west of the
application
site and the next one nikki is a closer
up shot of
this which then shows the building so
many of these photographs are taken from
the applicant's
own submissions chair so it's all
available information
on the portal this shows a closer view
of those buildings the tractor shed on
the right
and you can see what in officers opinion
is a very simple
agricultural style building with limited
openings that's just the one opening in
the front elevation the
stable on the left has got the openings
in this the elevations facing us but
for example on the stable building that
end elevation would be
all glazed thanks nikki
this is taken from the dali road this is
the
back of those buildings and you can see
the the tractor shed on the left
and you can see the existing stable on
the right with the single
rear opening in that elevation the
photograph we've just
seen is from the towards those dwellings
that you can see in the distance
thanks nikki and a close-up shot of that
thank you
and a couple of photographs share the
the site access this is taken
in the direction of chesterfield and if
you go on one nikki please
and that's in the matlab direction and
the public footpath runs
along this this track towards the
application site
thanks nikki and that's just looking
from the entrance so
the building that occupies the view in
the
beyond the site entrance which was
standing on across the road
thanks nikki
looking in the other direction this is
now looking back towards the side you
can see the public footpath
signpost on the right hand side there
the access track
leads towards the two buildings thanks
nikki
and that's further along that track you
just get to see the the tractor shed
in the distance now through those trees
thanks nikki
this is taken from the southern extent
of the
application site the area in the
foreground before the post rail fence
will be retained as
the grassland with the area beyond that
being
garden to serve the new dwelling but
again you can see the buildings in the
um middle right with the bottom of those
the
block work be refaced in stone with the
upper area being clad
in wood boarding just on the left here's
an existing
property myrtle grove thanks nikki
there's a view from the eastern
element of the the site again looking
back towards the tractor shed
thanks nikki
this is an area that would be used as
garden
and you can see the dali road just
beyond the
stone boundary wall in the in the far
distance
and this is uh the other element of
concern that officers have the area
in the foreground will become garden
with the usars as a garden that would
contain all the trappings that would be
associated with that and
concerned officers have with regards to
the impact of that on the
current carriage of the area thanks
nikki
you can just see the tractor shed in the
far right is looking across the
application site
the garden would be retained this side
of the
timber post rail fence thanks nikki
and this uh close-up shots some we've
seen previously
in the just cash your lines back to the
proposed
details which show for example on the
front elevation the tractor shed that
current opening you can get glaze with
the glazing then extended up to the
apex of the roof the same on the front
of the stable building
thanks vicky this is looking from
the east of the application site towards
the tractor shed
thank you
and signally thanks nikki
and i think this may be the final one
that's a close-up of the the front
elevations that are proposed
i think that maybe if you just go on one
and again
and again
thank you thank you chair
thank you are there any points needed
for clarification before i
ask the speakers councillor cooper
yes thanks chair just just to check have
these
um buildings ever actually been used for
their
their intended purpose i know they've
not been up that long
but they don't look in in a bad
condition at all so just
just check in really see if they've ever
been used for intended purpose
i i'm unable to answer that question
here unfortunately i don't know
the details of the building's use i can
tell you that the
as i just mentioned the stables was
granted consent back in 2005
the the tractor shed was granted consent
as recently as 2016. that i can't want
to actually tell you
if and when they're ever used as a as a
stable or a trap to store
yeah you've reached the conclusion that
the
uh the landscape
uh it's the impact on the landscape of
the garden
uh and also the other now
if we go back to the photographs which
you did which you showed for the
a distance at a landscape photograph
which you had
a bit previously uh it was
uh what you could see there was the
peak edge hotel standing out like a sore
thumb and
you could hardly see the uh the proposed
building
it blended in quite nicely and i can't
really see how
there's uh an impact of a garden
you know i can't say that adrian perhaps
you could explain
i'm happy to come back as appropriate
but you may want to um
hear from from speakers before
i think that'll be the best course thank
you
okay so we have two speakers for this
application
the applicant damien duckdale
good afternoon mr duckdale you have
three minutes yes good afternoon
i'm ready to go now sorry okay thank you
and good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
um i'm the afternoon damian dougdahl and
i previously lived at the house myrtle
grove next door to the site
uh i also owned and built the pcatch
hotel
following granting and planning
permission for holiday lodges at the
pikachu hotel
myself my wife and two young children
were ostracized locally
so much so we had to sell up and move
away
first the hotel and then our home myrtle
grove next door
the buyer of myrtle grove did not wish
to purchase the barns
stables workshop and track to stall
therefore they were left
unexpectedly redundant i want to turn
them into something of high quality make
the best use
of vacant buildings like i did with the
peak edge hotel
and the renovation of myrtle grove over
the past
20 years i've invested millions
into the local area north northeast
derbyshire
employing over 100 people in the
business i built up at the hotel
i generally do care about the local area
i employed a local planning consultant
and used local
architect to design a fitting scheme
that followed the advice on the local
planning policy requirements
i commissioned a bat survey an ecologist
report
a structural survey trying out any
issues that might we might foresee and
fully addressed before making the
application
i'm very surprised at the refusal given
i followed the policy requirements
of the council's own consultant officer
who initially told us in an email
that everything was uh compliant to
conservation policies
and value i was very willing to engage
and amend anything to the scheme should
the planning officer
wishes to but i was told nothing would
make the scheme acceptable
following comments from the playing
office report to you
i have checked the structural integrity
of the stables and they do not require
further structural work
to convert them into my planned scheme
i'm aware of a lot of bond conversions
in the surrounding area
and i cannot understand why mine is
unacceptable
i would employ local contractors use
local materials
if the scheme was approved
like the other high quality developments
i have proudly completed locally
so i'm asking you to support this
application to create an
attractive sensitive development out of
an empty redundant building
thank you thank you are there any
questions from mr doctyle
counselor elliot thank you chair
uh mr dugdale just a quick one um i
heard it asked earlier whether the
building was used for the purpose it was
intended
uh would you enlighten us on that one
please
yeah of course um we we use the the
track to store
and and the stables for for equipment
storage for when we developed
managing the land and and we i planted
six thousand trees you'd be pleased to
know
uh without anyone asking me to and uh
ultra hawthorne hedgerows around there
the primitives of that building they've
all got hawthorn
uh hedgerows which which i wanted to
reinstate were never there before
um and uh they were used to as a
facility for the hotel
we were producing our own for political
owned crops and things and migrate
you know things and eggs and basically
mowing the grass and keeping the
land we were castiogens off in a
shipshape fashion really yeah
so they were used yet i i'm asking
because i actually know they were used
i'm just
asking for the benefit of my fellow
colleagues
thank you thank you
mr doctor and i've got one question for
you and i'm no builder so
uh please i just need to be put right on
this when you build barns and stables
etc
do you have sufficient footings to take
this sort of
window scape because i believe you'd
have to have huge steel girders to take
that sort of weight
yeah yeah the very substantial footings
with steel in them
because the weight of tractors and
equipment is substantial
you know many tons of equipment moving
in and out so the buildings um i like to
do things properly in future booth
things so when that was built
it was built with a proper footing to
enable it to be
um used for very heavy equipment running
over and in it so it's very
strong a steel frame that will take an
upper floor
whereas the stables uh don't require any
further
uh sort of um construction work because
there's only a single
story in there they're not there's no
weight load bearing on that at all
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you mr duckdale and the next
speaker is charlotte stanton
hello charlotte hello thank you three
minutes
your planning policies are supportive of
the conversion of existing buildings
there are no criteria in these policies
which state that the building must have
been constructed for a specific number
of years
the age of the buildings is not relevant
to your decision
in any case as you've just heard the
stable building was originally
constructed in 2005
of over 15 years ago and were used by
damian and his family
and damien has explained why the bill
why the buildings have become
unexpectedly redundant there are four
relevant tests first is the building
permanent
and substantial we have submitted a
structural report prepared by two
professional engineers
and the council structural engineer has
raised no comments
the report concludes that the buildings
are structurally capable of conversion
why would your planet planning offices
reach a different conclusion
i hope you can see that the buildings
are both permanent and substantial
and this is evident from the photos
you've just seen
the second test with the scheme need
major
rebuilding or extension the structural
report and plans have demonstrated that
major rebuilding and
extension is not proposed there would be
a simple glaze link between the two
buildings
and that is the only new build element
the third criteria would the design and
appearance be in keeping with the
existing buildings and the surroundings
we we believe we worked with the
existing building to design
an attractive scheme there are various
comments about materials and windows in
the committee report
and we repeatedly made it clear to the
planning officer
that damien is very willing to revise
the designing materials
if we firmly believe however that the
conversion is
sensitive to both the existing buildings
and other properties in the landscape
the final policy requirement asks you to
consider the
cartilage the proposed garden and
parking areas use the existing areas
which you've seen in the photographs
which are enclosed by stonewalling and
fencing and are separate from the fields
damien would welcome any conditions to
control garden outbuildings lighting
surfacing boundary treatments and
landscaping as you usually would with a
conversion
based on our experience of bond
conversions we firmly believe that this
scheme complies with your relevant
policies
despite asking several times we received
no detailed feedback so that
damian could consider amendments
if you are not able to to support the
scheme in its current form and of course
we hope you are
please consider deferring the
application and asking officers to work
with us on the details
there have been no neighbour comments
and no objections from any technical
consultees
we acknowledge officer comments about
impact on the countryside
but ask you to know the photograph
earlier that
that the peak edge hotel with
substantial lighting and a large
extended house at metal grove
are both next door given this context
it seems very unlikely that the
conversion would be prominent in the
landscape
thank you thank you are there any
questions
counselor elliot thank you chair
uh just one for charlotte uh charlotte
when when we see the glazed
front of the building or what's
potentially going to be the glazed front
is that going to travel right up to the
apex of the ridge height
and is that i'm assuming is going to be
either a second floor or a staircase or
something is it oh yes there's the first
floor proposed in the detractor store so
the intention was to use that front
area to light as much of that floor as
possible
therefore i think yeah therefore
reducing the need for additional windows
down the side
um we thought that it was more in
keeping to have a big opening in the
front
um of the building having said that if
members were concerned we'd be
happy to accept a condition that some of
those um
be panels rather than glazing if that
would make the scheme more acceptable
and this was the sort of thing that we
were keen to negotiate with the officers
i'd almost be inclined to see it stoned
up and
stone flagged roof but you know we'll
see how the questions go thanks very
much
thank you are there any further
questions
counselor armitage
uh thank you chair uh it's just the uh
the landscape appearance that uh does uh
people well the officer has made uh
note of this uh and it was one of the
things that
they didn't like uh could you
uh enlighten us about this you know
about the landscape when we compared it
to the surrounds
the existing landscape is characterized
by
um the large peak edge hotel
which has been extended over many years
and i'm sure many of you are familiar
with and
and was shown in the photograph earlier
um as well as
myrtle grove which was previously owned
by
damian and again has been extended over
the years with
planning commission and benefits from a
large garden which is immediately next
to this site
there are agricultural fields um
around but it's not a pristine landscape
with green fields it's a
working landscape and it's a landscape
that includes
farms and houses thank you
thank you other questions
no thank you charlotte thank you
adrian you wanted to come back in
i know um i'm intending to come back
into the environment chair of course
i'll
seek to help advise members and members
ask
about assistance chair okay thank you
are there any questions now for uh
adrian
councillor elliott councillor armitage
after yeah
thank you chair um adrian can i i i've
read
i've read this through quite extensively
because i
could could you flick to the picture
from bellin lane
that shows the peak edge and myrtle
grove and and the
and the farm building we have a picture
there that that shows
just how dwarfed it is in in the
landscape
underneath the pikachu hotel i'm
struggling to find
if if this was actually stoned up and
and made into a dwelling
where we would where we i'm struggling
to get my own head while we're
while we're refusing it
if you may be able to uh to go back to
the the slide i think it's the first one
of this
this group yeah not not that one it's
the one that's staying from bell and
lane
that's
the i saw for me and the one i always
wanted to see
screen was that was that shot from
belland lane
and the huge um the huge thing that is
the bedrooms and so on at the peak edge
hotel
when i look down past myrtle grove and i
see that's been built up and stoned up
and extended
and we gave it permission and there are
quite a lot along that
uh dali road that uh that are like that
that we've agreed
that one that's quite dwarfed in its
character for me i'm very surprised with
the ra
we've got to refusal for it
and if you could just enlighten me a
little bit
certainly check first of all as members
will
you know you you need to look at the
policies of your development plan and
then assess whether there's any other
material issues that
affect that consideration and your
development plan
seeks to allow the change of use of the
versions of buildings
as your policy says providing they
regard
local distinctiveness and design and the
character of the area as
um charlotte's mentioned when she spoke
to members
and then so first of all you need to get
to assess that and in this instance we
have
utep utilitarian style building that
in normal circumstances officers
wouldn't support its conversion to a
dwelling in
buildings in the countryside that you'd
be seeking to retain are those of
some character stone-built buildings for
example and
not large-scale utilitarian-style like
cultural building buildings such as this
and you'll remember um at last committee
about the debate about
the building of dash overhey where
members were concerned about
an additional um six by six building in
the countryside
that had resulted from other conversions
of buildings that had taken place
so in this instance chair when remember
when officers are looking at the scheme
first of all we're looking at the
character the existing building i would
say
we wouldn't normally encourage the
conversion of these sort of
large agricultural style buildings we're
looking at the smaller
and more character buildings certainly
in my opinion but if i can ask members
to to look at their pages of the
drawings on page 40 to 41
when you're looking at whether the
significant alteration or
amendment to the to the scheme to in
terms of the materials the the scale the
form the general design and appearance
officers have looked at this and noted
the simple form of the buildings that
are there
and on page 41 i hope that exemplifies
the
the concern that officers have in that
the simple front
elevation would be transformed from that
block and
sheeting finish to one of stone
and timber cladding the entrance door
would be extended as you just turned
right
up to the apex of the roof and that
would all be glazed
on this thing that that front elevation
would all be glazed as opposed to the
current simple opening two garage doors
would be introduced into the front
elevation of the stable
the current side elevation of the
building would have openings introduced
to it again be stoned and
timber clad the roof lights would be
reduced from three to one
and to my mind and as officers take the
view and that's
significantly altering what is currently
the very simple form of character that
building
even if you consider that these
buildings are appropriate for conversion
in the countryside
so that's the concern that we always
offer is in that what you have at the
moment will be completely transformed in
terms of materials used
the openings that are there and the
character of that building so
so that's the first consideration that
you need to have if you
agree with officers that it doesn't meet
your
um basic development plan policy but
there are other factors that mitigate
that
and you talk about the pledge hotel then
you may take a view that's
overriding but if you disagree with
officers in terms of the first point
that actually the conversion does retain
the character of that building then
that will be in accordance with your
policies so it's just that officers take
the view that the level of alteration
would mean that
first of all irrespective of our concern
about the conversion of these stellar
buildings anyway
would officers take the very little that
building in its current form left in any
case
your materials are all altering you've
got significant changes to the openings
and couple with that you'd introduce
another residential cartridge into what
is currently
um a generally open agricultural
field but again you do need to take into
account the pks hotel
but ultimately each application on its
merits what do you develop plan policies
say
are there other considerations that then
outweigh that consideration
yeah can i come back to you is that okay
yes certainly hey it was just that
adrian made mention of a of another
another
application somewhere else in our
showroom i think it is
millennial wherever that was if if
if you'll indulge me chair i want to
make reference to an application just
last month for a stable block of
techington that we passed to be a
bungalow
you know and that had that had exactly
the same connotations and i think for
consistency we really need to be careful
what we
do allow and don't allow because i
cannot
not got rid of the horses but similar
with this one i think we need some
consistency
and i look at the peak edge and i look
at myrtle grove and i look at this
that's a redundant farm building it
either stays in
and falls to p falls to pieces or we
allow it to be stoned up and used as a
property
and and i think it would be less of an
eyesore than the back of the bedrooms or
at the
back of the hotel from belland lane or
anywhere else to be fair
thank you chair thank you
i think that's the that's consideration
that members have to
to to bear in mind and the one thing i
would say about the stables of
heckington is that the
existing openings were being used in
that instance
so the the overall and inherent
character of that building as a stable
would have had some
you would have read that still in the
converted building
thank you councillor hill yeah i agree
with councillor
elliot i would rather see this building
stone clad
and and uh
cladding on the side whatever has done
to it
has got to be far better than let it
stand there till it rots away
because then it does become an eyesore
in the countryside i just think it's a
shame that
you know we can't to see the vision
of it to place and being
made somewhere lovely for someone to
live
thank you thank you councillor armitage
uh yes sir chair thank you uh i'd just
like to take
adrian to task about the one that uh
attach over hey uh if we're comparing
because you mentioned it
i mean we don't usually compare one to
another but see you brought it up
uh this was a new build
it was outside the uh bloody the
settlement development limit this isn't
a new build
it's a redundant farm building or a
redundant building you've mentioned
about substantial modifications and
rebuilding
come on it's going to be the cell same
size it's going to be
re-cladded i wouldn't say that was
substantial
as regard the uh uh
the garden uh you know i can't see that
this is going to
stick out like a sore thumb and be an
adverse
uh thing in the uh in the countryside
i can't see that at all uh
peak edge hotel yes uh it's there but
uh mr dugdale did plant
an awful lot of trees that have yet to
come to
fruition they're only i think about
three or four feet high at the moment
but it will certainly soften the
landscape for this
uh application and also to the uh
pkh hotel and
you know it's in accordance to the uh
conversion policy
uh of northeast derbyshire this and
it's like counting
obviously has blended in beautifully
to the rest of the area you went against
the
one at uh wales at uh
opposite the miners arms at uh gin lane
there in oshawa
we uh went against officer's
recommendation
and it they made a beautiful job of it
when you didn't even want to see being
done
you know you've got to look forward to
these things and we had
a house in our show but right in the
middle
it's got a monopitch tin roof it's
glazed
all the way up the front and yes
when it was built everybody said what a
mess it looks
but you know it's been accepted now and
this planning authority
passed it so it isn't uh out of the
ordinary
it's uh an in innovative uh
building and i think we've got to do
we've got to stick with these it's a
redundant building are we going to make
use of it
thank you councillor
strangely enough i was just going to
bring that exactly the same one and
we're comparing one with another brow
which is going to say the one at mill
town
opposite the miners because it's exactly
the same sort of building and it does
look really really nice
um i'd also draw an issue with comments
about
light pollution when it's the side of a
hotel as big as that i think there's
already going to be
light going out into the open
countryside i don't think that's going
to make a lot of difference
at all
thank you adrian do you want to come
back with
anything just just very briefly if i'm
hr
i'm just seeking to advise members on um
policies in your development plan chair
it is for members to
interpret them and use them to determine
applications chair
but just to to mention policy gs7c
of the excellent local plan chair which
is
in terms of change of view superversion
just to remind members that
should be looking to grant permission
for changes of use
where the form scale massing materials
general design and appearance of the
development
respects the character and appearance of
the original building
the site and its surroundings with
particular regard to local
distinctiveness
and design and the policies of the
asheville enabled plan have policies
that reflect that too
thank you thank you
are there any other questions or
comments
counselor armitage
yeah i just pointed out adrian the ash
over here
one was a new building this is an
existing building
thank you all right i think we've
uh covered all we need to on this i'm
going to open the floor promotion
excuse me chad just before that bearing
in mind the way in which the debate's
gone would it be helpful if i just uh
reminded members about motions again yes
please
okay thank you chair uh please bear in
mind members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then the that amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation
then the member who has moved the motion
must forgive the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendation fails
or in other words it is not passed that
doesn't mean that the recommendations
are automatically approved rather you
will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations
or another course of action this will
need to be approved by the committee
through another vote thank you chair
thank you do i have anyone to put motion
forward counselor
yes please chair
counselor armitage thank you
yeah i'd like to go against uh officer's
recommendation
uh and i would like this uh application
to be uh passed uh and uh
the policy that i'm looking at is uh is
the
conversion policy gs7
and as far as i'm concerned it
does it doesn't fit any of the uh
arguments which adrian has put forward
as regards the landscape
thank you councilman earlier
you're muted
oh sorry chair technology it just
doesn't work routine
um i uh i'll second it chair i think
also the relevance of the policies ss1
sustainable development i think it will
be
i don't think it's over development in
the countryside ss9
and it is the reusable building in sdc1
so um and i really don't think it'll be
too detrimental where it is and
when it's grown up and softened with
sdc3 and landscape character
so providing providing we can put some
sort of condition in that
mr dugdale works with our planning team
with regards materials
and i i'd quite happily second that
thank you just if i may chair just to um
point out that the materials are clearly
set out to share on the submitted
details so
whilst i would ask that um if members of
mind to
approve the scheme and conditions are
delegated to himself in consultation
with yourself chair
materials are specifically set out so
materials wouldn't be a condition that i
would
suggest is imposed on on any approval
that's granted chair
okay thank you oh yeah
that's that's fine mummy chair but i
know adrian was concerned about the
um shall we say the the stuff that could
end up in the garden uh i think some of
that subjective with kids play equipment
and all the rest of it so i don't know
whether mr dukdale's got children or not
and
what ages they are that we could end up
with trampolines and bikes so
i i'd just like the the uh that the
applicant works with our planning team
to make sure we get the best out of it
lovely thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair uh providing council
armitage and councillor
are happy with this can we make it clear
uh in the motion
that with regards to gs7 that it's our
interpretation that it doesn't have an
adverse effect on the character of the
area
or nearing land users can we make that
uh clear there
and also that we are we support the uh
the conversion
uh of buildings like this that are all
in use to domestic
properties thank you thank you chad i'll
go along with that
uh chair thank you are there any other
comment motions etc no so it was
counsellor audi to you comfortable with
that
uh slight change yeah to be honest
um i'd actually said about the uh
the development in the and the landscape
character anyway but mark has reaffirmed
it and i'm quite happy that that's right
yeah
okay alan would you just like to confirm
what the motion would be
okay chair as i understand it uh the
motion is to approve the application
against officer recommendations uh for a
range of reasons
um set out um relating to various
policies such as gs7
um however i think the key point is is
that the uh
final conditions to be uh determined by
the planning
uh manager in consultation with yourself
is that the essence of it sure
as far as i'm aware yes everyone's
nodding their heads yep that's fine
okay off we go then you look for a vote
thank you chair if mother is completely
and hate fought against or abstain
counselor armitage or
cancer cooper against
cancer elliot four cancer foster
four cancer hill
[Music]
four cancer pots
against
cancer powell
cancer reader against
cancer rouse against
and councillor rough
sure that seven votes for four against
with zero abstentions is carried thank
you
thank you everybody and we move on to
our final planning application
which is twenty four slash zero zero
nine
three one forward slash foh and
ned forward slash twenty four slash
zero zero nine three two four slash lb
just to remind um everybody that there
are two votes on this one is for
planning and one is regarding a listed
build
excuse me chair um might to be
appropriate just have a very quick
um break uh before we move into the
application
do you know how members feel about that
yep yes please
yep uh 10 minutes might be back by uh
25 past three thank you
thank you martin okay as i say we're on
to our final
planning application for the afternoon
and this is the one at
adrian are ridgeway going to take us
through this one
yes thank you chad first of all i just
do a brief introduction then go through
the
slides with nikki if i may in this
instance chair
as you've already outlined i think we're
asked to determine both the planning
application and a link listed building
application for extension at downlands
farm
the site is locating the greenbelt chair
and the conservation area
and the farmhouse itself is a grade two
listed structure
previously and following discussion with
officers chair a single-story monopitch
roofed extension was approved at the
site and we'll see
plans of that in a second the current
applications chair seek consent
for a two-story double gabled extension
but on the same
floor footprint in terms of the planning
application
chair officers have concluded that
whilst the extension is not proportioned
in terms of its size
due to the location of the extension in
the crease of the building its impact on
green wild openness is very restricted
these represent the very special
circumstances that otherwise justify the
extension against green belt policy
however chairs members are well aware
special regard has to be paid to the
building's listed status
the single story extension chair was
approved as officers considered it had a
recessive
and simple form that overall retained a
simple primarily linear character of the
building
that reflected its historic use and form
however chair officers are concerned
about the two
two-story proposal and it's not
considered acceptable as it is
as you said two stories in height and
considered dilute the simple form and
character of the building covering up
existing features forming two odd and
unbalanced gable elements
and also introducing a horizontal
emphasis to the glazing guitars for the
generally vertical emphasis
of the building it's considered chair
that this represents harm that's not
outweighed by the predominantly personal
benefits to the applicant
officers as members will know the chair
also consider that this results in harm
to the conservation area
as such chair officers recommend refusal
of both the listed link building and
planning applications
that's that any decision to refuse the
application is generally in line with
the reasons set out from the officer
report
with any alterations to the wording
delegated to myself chair
thank you i just asked nikki to bring
the presentations up
thank you nikki the application site
chair it's
um slow lane at ridgeway it's in the
green wealth as i say the moss valley
conservation
area and it's a grade two listed
building and special regard
as i've just said chair need to be paid
to the desirability of preserving the
setting
of the listed building and the
conservation area the listed building
thanks nikki the application site share
in red
the dwelling house the subject of the
application is the
long linear building at the bottom of
the red line area chair
thank you
it's the proposed plan of the existing
the existing at the top
of the slideshare they proposed at the
bottom the
area of the extension is on the the top
drawing where it says patio you can see
that replicated then on the bottom
where the two-story extension proposed
and we've got elevations next i think
nikki
oh sorry in the platform i'm just
showing the
plan as proposed at ground floor and at
the first floor level so the existing
form and structure of the building at
the top which shows the
linear form of the existing dwelling
house
and that's part of its office's opinion
character
and then the proposed two-story floor
plans at the bottom
thanks dickie this is the elevations
chair you can see the top two drawings
the the existing
front and rear elevations and then you
can see the
proposed front and rear the next line
down
so the alterations to the to the front
and there aren't any
to the rear you can see then the two
additional gables that are proposed
as i say they aren't balanced one being
narrower and therefore
lower than the the other one and you can
see the the window detailing which is
generally horizontal in form rather than
the primarily
vertical emphasis that you can see of
the openings in the car sheds
and the window detailing at the moment
the current two-story gable that's there
and the window openings
thanks nikki just for clarification
chair to say
following discussion with officers a
single story mono pitched extension
was a proven you'd see that on the
second drawing down on the right hand
side
put a simple mono pitch roof and retain
the upper floor windows
and it's got the vertical emphasized
windows and the
lower ground area thanks nikki move on
to photographs now
the extension chair is proposed
in the crease of the building that's
formed by the right angle of the
building as it as it runs um primarily
linear which is the bit to the right
you can just see the projecting
two-story gable
that's there that's there currently on
the left-hand side of the photograph so
the
extension would fill in that area there
and single story extensive currently
proposed would also be in that area
as to say this proposed list for two
stories with the the double gabled
finish thanks nikki
and it's there it would be on the left
center of the
her trap is where the extensions would
be formed
thanks nikki and again
photographs certainly in an officer
opinion show the
predominantly simple and vertical
emphasis of the
openings in the building otherwise long
and thin
um and set out in the listing
description
and building dates back a number of
centuries
thanks nikki and these are some
photographs that mr moulton i believe
will speak to
shortly yeah i'm sure he'll uh he'll
talk about them as he
as he comes to speak to them but i'm i'm
not
entirely sure which um application they
refer to if one at all i couldn't find
any history with regards to
to renovation to refer back to well i'm
sure mr moulton will take
and was through those photographs
chairing due course thank you
thank you does anyone want a
clarification at this point
if not we'll move on to the speakers
nope
thank you we have four speakers this
afternoon
and the first speaker is the world
member councillor carolyn renick
caroline you have three minutes when
you're ready thank you madam chairman
good afternoon and uh
thank you for allowing me to call this
in to register my support for this
application
in fact i was surprised to see this
recommended refusal
as a council have already approved a
planning application for a single story
extension on the same
footprint however the applicants
couldn't wish to
simply amend to a two-story extension
allowing them a much-needed
living space to continue to accommodate
their two young
adults or full-time farmers on this site
the applicants are well-established
respected farming family who occupied
successful farm in this lane for
generations and 10 to 200 acres in
this parish alone i know this property
well i go pass it daily and despite
the photographs that you've seen at the
back of the house uh it is referred to
as a 17th century property i can
remember this is a hugely dilapidated
building
that was some 20 years ago in absolute
ruins and
subsequently care and synthetic and
significant renovations in the 90s
early 90s we have the home and the
working farm as you see it today
uh so i think the the obvious
presentation is a little bit misleading
because it
looks a little like what you would have
recognized as a 17th century building
20 years ago i'm hoping the applicant's
agent can show you a little bit about
how this has been
renovated over the last 20 years but
what they have done is actually enhance
and preserve
the long-term future of this listed
building
secondly i think the public benefits
outweigh any harm
it maintains a long local standing
farming family
in an area where affordable housing is
very poor
and it's you know for two 20 year old
farmers who are up at 5 30 in the
morning
i think that you know it's essential
that they are living on site
the property is actually very deceiving
it's just got three bedrooms it is
longer than except for the side the end
of the barn the side
so i'm keen to ensure that this council
supports a dedicated local working
farming family
on a farm of this scale so it can
continue to be sustainable for the next
generation
and also not forgetting to support the
food security in our area particularly
in these
difficult and uncertain times thirdly i
don't believe this small extension has
materially greater impact on the
openness when looking at its surrounding
area
and is not a prominent intrusion and
will continue to look linear and not
change the aspect at all
in fact on the contrary i believe this
application will preserve the listed
building and it's the
perpetuity used by and lived in by a
long-standing local farm
the next generation to come indeed
officers themselves have stated on page
58 seconds
that the negative impact on the openness
of the greenbelt of this application is
small
so i believe this truly meets the very
special circumstances it has raised no
objections locally
and after your careful consideration i
hope you will too see that this modest
extension
for what it is and approve this
application thank you
thank you are there any questions for
councillor
councillor foster yeah thank you chair
uh castlevanic uh this i've seen those
uh
those photos there about when it was run
down it when it was derelict
uh and i gather it was renovated roughly
around
1990 from what i understand
uh do we know how long it had been
developed and i'm lived in before that
just to give me some background
well well i i well i know i i don't know
because i
i i've not heard um the husband was he
would tell you exactly and
no doubt the agent managed to tell you
but for years i mean it's probably been
run down for
probably for decades and you'll see
hopefully there might be some
photographs to come i think someone
together from the
agent which might show you that the
absolute state it was in so
you know it was you know 17th century it
was probably a bomb
but between the 18th and 19th century um
it was probably still a balance and some
use but it was
it was not fit for any use um when i
first moved here 25 years ago
okay thanks any other questions
no thanks thank you councillor and we'll
move on to the next speaker
and i've got it down as laura nash as
the agent
yeah i understand that lauren ash is not
speaking with us today so your next
speaker would be
uh doug moulton okay thank you i've got
a helena kelly plan
issue speaking yes sure she is uh but
she'll be speaking second and she's
essentially i think going to look at the
um the history of the building
um doug moulton will be um taking the
role
essentially of the agent for this
purpose lovely thank you
yeah mr mountain yeah hi can everyone
hear me okay
yeah you've got three minutes when
you're ready okay many thanks
dallin's farm has been within the
applicant's family's wife for three
generations
the applicants moved into the house in
the 1990s
as known it was in a very poor state of
repair and dilapidated
the family has spent considerable time
and effort in maintaining the future of
the building
enhancing its long-term future so it's
secured
if nicola could just show those
photographs what we referred to earlier
i think the extent of the words cannot
be underestimated
and best demonstrated by these
photographs which actually show
the extent of what had to be rebuilt
around the gable
keeping the front elevation intact and
everything else has been
basically rebuilt by the applicant to
make it
livable as it is to now and to preserve
that building
downlands is a working farm he's got
this 1300 acres within five miles
and it's an active farm business and the
focal point of the farm
as you've heard it employs two sons who
are aged 23 and 21
and also the applicant's wife and they
have to be on care 24 hours a day
and they are very much the next
generation of the farm and will
insurance continue in excess contrary to
the officer report it is considered
there is public benefit
it will be continuously used as a family
home its optimum viable use
the application solely relates to the
additional story required to provide
additional bedroom space so the
applicant's sons can live
and work on the farm to ensure it can
function successfully
there's a significant shortfall of
affordable homes in the district
including ridgeway and it's difficult to
understand how the additional story to
the consensus single story extension
would have a level of harm to the
historic building to warrant a refusal
it's not visible from the front building
the proposed extension would be
integrated into the year of the build
to the rear of the building which has
been substantially rebuilt
being set back and the ridgeline lower
than the existing roof line a by fault
door
modernizes how the rear of the building
can be used to link the outside space
a common feature to modern buildings the
farm will retain its original
l-shaped layout notwithstanding the
extent permission for the single story
rear extension
it will remain as a group of buildings
and rural buildings of traditional
material
the surrounding countryside of the
building is setting will be
unchanged my colleague helena kelly will
focus on the heritage considerations of
the application in greater detail
the site is within the green belt and we
can concur with the office report
that the two-story extension would have
lived remain
on the in on the openness of the green
belt greenbelt particularly considered
exciting within the complex of existing
buildings
and the existing permission for a single
story extension on the identified
footprint
in setting out the context of the
specific need for the two-story
extension
and we consider minimal harm to the
listed building we respectfully request
that councillors support the proposal
and approve the application
thank you do we have any questions
councillor foster councillor earlier and
council of parts
uh thank you chair um yeah question for
mr moulton
uh regarding in our papers uh
item 7.9 our officers believe uh
this to have a negative impact on the
openness of the green belt
uh they say small but they say it's
nevertheless present
i wonder if we can yo yo that is an
interpretation
that uh as far as i'm concerned i wonder
what your interpretation was on
that uh that level of impact
okay well i think it's negligible
because because of the l-shaped grouping
of that building and
being tucked in tucked in that that
corner to the rear of the building
and the built form of the existing farm
buildings
and the fact that you've already got the
extent permission for the single story
extension the footprint of the building
has already been
is already going to change so it's about
that
there isn't there is an increase on the
open there is a change on the openness
because you're
doing that additional second story but
as it's tucked in tight to the l-shape
of the building
i think the overall impact on the
openness is like i say negligible
okay with that council foster yeah yeah
so it just cut off at the end but yeah
thank you mr moulton
thank you can i answer elliott thank you
chad
it is uh pretty much in line with what
counselor foster's just asked
and it was about the openness mr molten
you when i looked at some pictures and i
only briefly saw it earlier and that was
when the footings and some of the breeze
was going upon the
on the long part of the building it
looked like the rear of it
was actually into a mound of earth is
that
is that now on to open landscape or is
it still fairly
fairly high with earth at the back of
that building
uh sorry i'm just trying to when you
which picture are you looking at
uh well i can't see it obviously i'm
looking at yourself
but yeah it looked like it was the
original i could see a white
a white lined wall where all the
building was was in
in tatters and you were building the the
breeze on the front
what looked like out of the back of the
front side of the building but it looked
like it was built into a bank
and yeah i think did i see that right
way or wrong yeah
the where the where the sort of
extension is
is to be proposed is where the existing
patio is
and that's set lower down into that
corner of the
of the of the gable and the and the rear
building
obviously that that rear elevation which
the
which the um extension is going to
connect to the building is but has been
what's been comprehensively rebuilt
through the previous
renovations of the building and then
obviously where
i mean to be fair i've these these
pictures are from the applicant alan
finley
and i actually went to see him to look
at the building and he and luckily he
had all pictures of how the building had
sort of changed over exactly yeah and we
spent a good
deal of time looking through them i mean
i could have given you about 50
so i just tried to get somewhat with the
most representative
and and i think this has done it's
really well about how the building's
mid 90s and and and how it sits
and then obviously where that pile of
rubble is that's now been
landscaped but that would still exist
because the extension would be in the
lower bit where the patio is now which
at the end of the day
dark and not very useful that that's
what i was aiming at so so the
the the huge mound of rubble's actually
now flattened on
absolutely that's all being landscaped
and that's it yeah i think the clearest
way to say is that's a historic photo to
show
how it's been brought back to the slides
that are in the office of presentation
thanks very much okay
hello mr moulton um could i ask you
please you've obviously said that it's
not
this this extension wouldn't be visible
from the front because it's at the rear
but at the rear of the property can you
confirm
or otherwise whether there are any
public footpaths um
to the rear of the property and would it
be visible um
to users of the countryside from the
rear
the elevation of it i would to be honest
with you i'd have to check that myself i
can do that now if you want to give me a
few minutes i can
i can check for you and come back to you
on that point on public footpaths and
views from the rio
yes please if you would they looked on
one of the photos as if it was sort of a
woodland behind
it um but i don't know if there are any
public footpaths through there but if
you would please that'd be great
give me five minutes i'm happy to
clarify that would planning officers be
able to help on that
alan hello would it be possible for
councillor renick to um come forward on
this because
she's local she'd have more knowledge on
this uh councillor renick spoke i'm
afraid
as a ward member and she's answered her
questions
uh so from our point of view she can't
have any further involvement
in the meeting thank you
right are there any other questions no
we'll come back to you mr morton when
you've been able to find out that
information or whoever comes first
but i don't know if adrian will be able
to pick any of that up
unfortunately chair i'm i'm about to
wear the rock he writes away to the
more than willing to have a quick look
now to try and give you some
clarification on that if you'd like to
say
just give me five minutes i'll try and
do a desktop now
okay thank you we'll move on then to um
helena kelly
you've got three minutes elena thank you
can everybody hear me okay yes
thank you hi so i'm good afternoon
everybody i'm helena kelly i'm the
heritage consultant for the applicant
and i wrote the heritage statement with
the application
um i assessed that there was the
application would result in a
very low level of harm to the listed
building and i find the harm to it a
very low level because
the proposed extension would have a
negligible impact on the historic
structure
it links to the house through the modern
rebuilt barn that we've just been
looking at
and the elevation that would be affected
by the proposed extension
was rebuilt in the 1990s and the
architectural
detailing on that elevation such as
window openings were changed
then and there are some photographs in
the heritage statement that show that
and the south elevation of the property
the front elevation
is as we saw from the plans unaltered by
the current proposals
and a lot of the architectural detailing
described in this description is on that
front elevation
and non-supplies on this back elevation
has been
rebuilt in the 1990s and the extension
would not be visible
above the roofline of the house and it's
designed to be in keeping with its
character and appearance
there are examples of farmhouses in
north east derbyshire with double gables
um such as fanshawe gate hall um troy
hall
and hag hill house and they are all also
listed as grade two
17th century farm houses so very
equivalent to darland
and down farmhouse itself has an
l-shaped plan
and that's in the list description as
well and the proposed extension respects
that
and maintains that l-shaped plan and the
proposal does not
significantly distract from that
historic plan of the farmhouse
the scale and mass of the proposed
extension is not significant compared to
the mass of the farmhouse and barn range
and the linear form of the farmhouse and
barn
um would remain readily apparent
and the courtyard yard arrangement of
the
farmhouse and barn and other
agricultural buildings to the front of
the farmhouse
would be unchanged the historically
domestic and agricultural parts of the
building
would continue to be reared as distinct
elements as they do now
despite the use of the modern barn in
part of extension to the
house living accommodation and the
glazing would be in relation to a modern
extension
and would help to make a distinction
between the modern and historic elements
of the property
and the proposed glazing would not
introduce any irreversible change to the
historic building
um government guidance requires that
where there's potential harmful 30
seconds remain
that that harm is categorized either
less than substantial or substantial and
that within that category the extent of
the harm is clearly articulated
and here i find the heart to be at the
lowest dent of less of the scale effects
less than substantial
and that should be weighed against the
public benefits and again government
guidance is clear
the benefits do not always have to be
visible or accessible
to the public in order to accessible to
the public to be genuine public benefits
and the example given in guidance is
works to enlisted private dwelling which
secure its future
could be a public benefit thank you
that's time chair
thank you are there any questions
counselor foster
uh yeah uh question for elena uh when we
look at
uh that definition you mentioned you
mentioned
which is uh the less than substantial
harm to the
uh significance of a designated heritage
asset
it's got to be weighed against public
benefits uh
what struck me is not the fact that the
building itself would be a public
benefit the preservation of that
uh that as a farm is a working farm but
for me what struck me
is uh the fact that it's
not just a working farm but it's about
food production it's about
food security and i wondered in in if in
your opinion
that food security and food production
for that area
as well as providing employment would be
considered this is in your view
would that be considered a public
benefit
um i mean i'm a heritage consultant so
it's probably a little bit beyond my
remit to
to say but from the heritage perspective
it is listed as a 17th century farmhouse
this property has been associated with
local food production
for hundreds of years and continuing
that
continuing that that viable use is i
think something that could be termed a
public benefit
and i think that's that follows the
guidance on what a public benefit is
thank you thanks thank you
any other questions
mr morton are you able to come back with
your
answer regarding footpath etc
i think it's disappeared mr olsen
hello i've um i've been on the dobbs
county council mapping portal
and um the closest footpath to uh
dowling's farm is
um that's your footpath uh 32
which goes from um slowed lane to the
south of
the farm from a um in an easterly
direction towards the
saint john the evangelist church i don't
know if there's a plan that we can
we can see just to uh
to demonstrate that to show that
so you can see on the on the plan
there's a
um towards the
um towards the bottom uh right hand
corner there's you can see the word path
oh yes yes so that is the footpath it
goes from the road
which is to the um to the left of the
word path
so and then it goes goes in a uh a
off the page to a in a easterly
direction
so if the arrow can follow do the arrow
that's the road then the footpath goes
the opposite way so no the opposite way
towards path
and then off where it says 103.8
in that direction right so that's that's
a definitive footpath that's
eckington footpath number 32. thank you
thank you for that jim
yeah apologies for that i couldn't get
back onto the zoom meeting momentarily
that's fine thank you so at least we
know where no is that okay
for you so if i'm interpreting that
correctly the back of the building
isn't visible from that footpath it's so
frustrating because i want to ask
i want to ask caroline rennie because of
residence
um but from my interpretation of that of
that
and that explanation that uh that's just
been given i i take it that it's not
visible
excuse me chair could cancel a renek um
turn off her camera i think for these
purposes
that's normal practice for rip witnesses
once they've
spoken thank you thank you are there any
sorry can i just apologize the um
the the actual occupants just sent me a
text on the footpaths
i don't know if that would help for a
bit more clarity
okay is that apologies
um he said the land behind is in is
is in finley's ownership in the woodland
and then obviously the footpath is to
the right of the property and runs away
as the council's comments so yeah no
visibility from the rio
thank you thank you for that so any
further questions
no i'll open the floor for comment and
debate
counselor reader counselor foster
yeah chat um i have real concerns
about this um i'll be honest you know
we're talking about something that is
happening in the green belt
and you know we want to protect the
green belt
and stop things from sprawling out and
looking
inappropriate so they already have
planning
consent for a single story and so my
feelings are i don't understand how
adding an extra story to this is going
to
add any extra value to this spot to the
farm
or with regards to the building and i'm
i'm being asked to trust
the experts and our officers and our
officers feel that they're
however it might be you know a low level
part of harm to
to this building but my feeling is it is
still harm to this building
so i'm yet to be convinced here
uh yet by what i'm hearing that it's
appropriate to
to be doing this to a heritage uh
listed building so i'm i'm still open
to the conversation but i'm just putting
it out there that i have
real concerns about this
uh thank you chair uh i'll speak about
both those that counselor reader brought
up before uh uh
speak a little further uh the one about
the the green belt
uh the aim of the green belt is to
prevent sprawl uh
by keeping land permanently open if you
look at where it hit where it is much
like
uh the architect pointed out mr moulton
it's just
in filling for me part of a building so
i don't think for me
uh i think i do believe it is negligible
when it comes to
affecting the openness uh so there is
one
it is there and it does affect it but
it's negligible that's what i believe
that can then be outweighed by public
good
it can be outweighed and it says that in
the policy it says that in the mppf
uh when it comes to um harm
to heritage that's much the same that
can be outweighed as well and i think
that's what we're being asked
as members to deliberate on i'm sorry i
can't tell you
counselor either uh so uh that's the
first part the end of the green belt is
to prevent sport sprawl
uh for me this is only the change from a
single extension
into a double extension um
let's have a look where was i going next
um
it's not a pr inappropriate development
in the green belt
there's exceptions in 7.8 of the pack
page 58 exceptions including extensions
or alterations of a building providing
there be no impact
on openness so this is an extension
now while it's not a single extension
any longer it's a double extension
uh further to that i i believe it's
negligible
the difference that it makes and then
moving further on to the heritage much
like when i asked the question
to the heritage uh consultant if we look
how it's defined on 7.22 of page 61
our officers um
consider it to lead to less than
substantial harm to the significance
it's less than substantial harm
uh to the significance of a designated
heritage
asset uh this harm should be weighed
against public benefits of the proposal
now what was speaking about earlier when
i mentioned that the public benefits
here i believe it's not just about
providing extra housing
for an existing working farm where
you've got four adults
so you've got a family of four people
living together in a currently a
three-bedroom
property this means that they can
continue working and to continue to
continue working in this working farm
providing for me food security providing
employment i know that they work cattle
and they work
sheep over the 200 acres so there's more
than enough public benefit for both the
green belt issue
the negligible harm to the green belt
the openness of the green belt
absolutely negligible and it says in the
summary and conclusion
of page 62 8.1
so whilst the harm is identified is
considered to be less than substantial
it again makes that point there uh we've
got to weigh up here whether those
public benefits outweigh that small harm
um so for me it's clear it's more than
clear
this is just an infill from a it's it's
as easy as it's an infill
of a of the back of a building that
nobody sees
there's already going to be a single
extension there this is only moving it
to a double extension
it provides four bedrooms rather than
three bedrooms it's not as though
they're doing anything uh much different
apart from providing limit
uh living accommodation uh it was
derelict in the first place from the
1990s
uh this is about uh providing a working
farm
of five working adults and keeping our
food production up so i'm more than
happy to support this
uh that it goes through and we go
against officers recommendations
because we can hear quite simply we make
the judgment here
that those public benefits outweigh that
small harm
it's small even when you look at it from
what the officers
have described it i believe it's less
than small so i'm quite happy to
support this application thank you thank
you
councillor cooper then councillor
armitage and councillor elliot
thank you chair well while i agree with
some of the
some of the comments that council
fosters made i have to say that
i do agree with cancer reader
it it may be seen as infilling a small
infill
but in my opinion it's it's out of
character the design
is out of character with that with that
building
and that's that's all i'd like to say at
this moment
thank you councillor armitage
uh thank you chair i agree with
everything that
uh council apostate said they think that
uh
he he hasn't touched on is the fact that
uh in time somebody will have to move
out and
they'll have to travel backwards and
forwards to the
to the farm and you know we're trying to
reduce carbon aren't we uh as regards
the
style the footprint isn't any bigger
which has already been passed and
they're
putting a twin gable end
i think it's a looks a better design
than the one that's already been
designed
thank you can australia
thank you chair um yeah it's really just
to carry on from
from what council of foster said when
i'll when i look at this
and i'll look at uh paragraph 718 on
page 60.
it sits down and states about paris
184202 of the mppf
the heritage assets should be conserved
in a manner appropriate to their
significance
so they can be enjoyed for the
contribution to the quality of life
of existing and future generations
well if we don't if we don't help out
the existing generation
now on a working farm
you know i'm sort of with mark foster
that
something so small on on the back of
this
it doesn't really encroach in the green
belt that much
and as we've rightly said the footprint
is there already
it's essentially another another lift on
that one
single extension and i know mark
mentioned
7.8 but if you look at 7.9 similar
the scale of the two-story extension uh
like elements of that seal and other
nearby buildings the impact on the
openness
is small or tiny but nevertheless
present
it's tiny so we've really got to look at
the thing in the hole
and i think to support a working farm in
the greenbelt
is is the way forward i'm sort of with
mark foster on this
thank you you know we're keeping alive
we're keeping a family together and the
livelihood going
yeah very important any other comments
counselor reader yeah can i just uh
make a point here i have not against
here
i've said i want to keep an open mind
with this
right to the end i said at the beginning
of what i said
as i was waiting to hear some evidence
of it i'm still concerned about it i did
raise my points of why i'm concerned
but i feel very much that i'm being sort
of
target with this brush that i'm against
sort of supporting a working form
and that is absolutely not what i was
saying i was talking about my concerns
about
the green belt and openness of that
preventing sprawl
into that we if we're setting a
precedence with this
and and also the concern around our
heritage site and i'm still sticking
with those thoughts but i will keep an
open mind
while the debate is going on thank you
counselor adrian
yes thank you hopefully um just throw
some of this
together hopefully to help members but
there are two elements here chair two
different
applications the first is a planning
application
which you should be looking at in terms
of your policies in respect of
greenbelt development and as has been
debated that
it needs to be set aside from the listed
building application so
in terms of greenbelt impact extensions
to dwelling houses
are only not inappropriate if they are
proportionate to the existing dwelling
so that's the first consideration to
degree belt
members need to assess is the extension
proportionate if it's not it's
inappropriate development and you should
only be granted permission for it
for very special circumstances and they
should be special
which would be very special so not
normal run-of-the-mill
circumstances in an officer opinion
chair
the size of the extension we don't
consider it proportionate to the
dwelling
but in this instance because of the site
specifics it set it within the crease of
that building
and therefore in addition to the single
story edition that's been granted
officers on balance consider they are
very special
site specific circumstances that justify
the inappropriate development in this
case and members will need to take a
view on whether first of all
it is proportionate if it is not
proportionate inappropriate development
you must need them to look at very
special circumstances
if you consider it disproportionate then
it's appropriate developed in the green
belt
and you don't need very special
circumstances
in terms of the issue of the listed
building share
the issue that you have in your policies
is that
development affecting listed buildings
should um
be appropriate to the historic form
setting detailing of the existing
building that differs
slightly from the mppf which talks about
harm substantial harmless substantial on
if i can just go through that very
briefly check
the mppf talked about
harm in its totality it's where a
heritage asset is disposed of demolished
or is lost so that would normally be the
complete demolition of
the building for example this
is proposal for an extension
and by definition in my opinion anyway
and impact on the list of building must
have some
detrimental impact or else you'll be
seeking to preserve the building in its
current form
but the mppf only talks about less than
substantial harm as opposed to
complete and utter harm but then it sets
out that there is probably a scale
of level of less than substantial harm
so you need to take view first of all on
where that falls
and in officer opinion the impact of the
extension on that form and detailing the
listed building
is at the higher end of less than
substantial
because of the details proposed the
double gabled finish with the doesn't
match onto the existing there is on the
back for example
it takes away the current features the
element of the building is more
horizontal vertical all the issues that
i mentioned before
and therefore if you and i i believe you
do need to
conclude that there is less of a
substantial arm on whatever element of
the scale that is and council foster
believes that it's on the
bottom end of the scale officers take it
take a different view but that's a view
that you will need to take a
decision on where that then falls you
need to assess whether there are any
public benefits that our way that harm
and if you're on the lower end of the
scale as councillor foster suggested he
would be
then the public benefits don't need it
quite a higher threshold
as say an officer view would be and
officers take the view that the
benefits here are primarily private and
therefore the public benefits are
limited not outweighing the harm
and just to to help share in terms of
what is meant by the term public benefit
the guidance set out in the planning
practice guidance
sets out that public benefits may follow
from many developments and could be
anything that delivers economic social
or environmental objectives
as described in the national planning
policy framework
public benefits should flow from the
proposed development
they should be of a nature or scale to
be a benefit
to the public at large and not just be a
private benefit
however benefits do not always have to
be visible or accessible to the public
in order to be genuine public benefits
for example works to a listed private
dwelling which secure its
future as a designated future heritage
asset
could be a public benefit for example
and it goes on to also say
examples of hote benefits are sustaining
or enhancing the significance of that
have an asset
the contribution to its setting reducing
or removing risk risks to it
and to create optimum viable use
i hope that's helpful chair but i do
members need to
to to differentiate the planning
elements of this
to listed building elements of this and
the fact that
be public benefits could be very special
circumstances in terms of the green belt
impact which are probably more properly
addressed in terms of the impact to the
heritage asset
and this issue of less than substantial
harm i do hope that
helps chair but there are two distinct
elements and need to be treated as such
okay thank you any other comments
questions no i'm going to open the floor
then promotions
council foster yeah
in line with what mr kirkham said there
i am happy to propose that
we give this planning permission both
the listed element
and for uh the green belt element as
well
um the first one and that uh
from what i understand from what you've
said uh adrian
uh that it is appropriate so we don't
need special circumstances
because it is just uh that extra story
it is just one extra bedroom and it's
private it's away from the
uh the view of the public there's no
path around the bike
and it is infilling just in the crease
of a building
so for me that it is appropriate
development so that's the first one
uh second one uh that i'm happy with
that uh that double gable
i don't find that looks out of place at
all uh not one bit
i know uh the that they're offset
there's a smaller gable on the larger
cable but you often see that in the
countryside anyway
so i don't find that uh inappropriate at
all uh
when it comes to those public benefits i
do believe those are public benefits it
is
uh securing this property as a heritage
asset so i'd like to put that forward
as well but in addition it is about
supporting a working form
it's about providing jobs it's about
providing food security
and providing local food so i think
there's
there's lots uh here that um
that point is in that direction and i
believe uh
that less than substantial harm much
like you've said is much on the lower
end of the scale and not on the on the
higher end of that scale it's on the
lower end of that scale and it's
outweighed
by those public benefits so i'd like to
propose it
that we give planning permission for
this uh application on that basis
i'll second that got hands going up
everywhere
excuse me chair um from our point of
view then are we taking both of these
together or would it be
more appropriate to take each
application separately
i'd be happy for both together
both together i think it's less
confusing for everybody
yeah okay just to clarify adrian have
you got any concerns about that
um i don't chair i i personally would
have
asked for two votes but writing all
members are
satisfied that um that all elements are
contained within that boat chair
and members are in their own minds
having the two different
elements chair then then that would be
acceptable just just to
um conclude chair members are minded to
grant consent
would that be with conditioned
delegation to myself in
consultation with yourself and finally
chair just to
be clear that um council fosters putting
this forward in terms of
the extension being proportionate and
therefore appropriate development in the
green belt
and also that there is
the less than substantial harm the lower
end of the scale
and that's outweighed by the public
benefits so both those elements are
disentangled and and set out in that
form so i believe that's what counts the
fact that's exactly that
that's it thank you chair i do have
concerns about
uh having the um just the one vote for
the two separate
applications uh i'd be concerned that if
um
if the application is turned down we
wouldn't know whether um
members were voting against both
both the um planning permission and the
listed building consent i think
in order for us to know for sure what
members feelings are i think we should
have
two separate votes okay i'll bow to your
judgment jim we're going to go for two
votes
so that would be the first one on the
application
zero zero nine three one flh
uh the proposed two story read extension
effectively the
uh motion there is is to go against
office recommendations
and to grant planning permission i
believe so
counselor are you happy for the reasons
i've given to myself for the reasons
i've set out
uh in the meeting with any conditions uh
to be determined by the planning manager
in consultation with the chair is that
the essence of the members
i do believe so council armitage yeah
everyone's happy with that okay nikki
we'll go for a vote now for that first
one
okay so the first photo you can clearly
say thought against or abstain
cancer armitage counselor cooper
against cancer elliot four
cancer foster four cancer hell
better you're on mute
or castle liggett
or cancer pots
or cancer powell
cancer reader against
cancer browse stain
cancer rough so chair that's uh
eight votes four two against with one
abstention and that is carried
thank you move on to vote two
yeah so again that is to uh go against
officer recommendation and to give
uh building consent to the application
again for the reasons set out uh in the
meetings with any final conditions to be
determined by the planning development
manager
in consultation with yourself is that
the essence of it members
i believe so is that okay counselor
foster thank you
okay okay uh so for the vote to be
clearly vote for
against or abstain counsel armitage
how's the cooper against
casa elliot four council foster
four how's the hill four
castle leggett four
cancer pots for
casa powell oh that's the reader
against casabras
stain and counselor rough
oh okay same result chef uh
eight four two against with one
abstention and that's carried
thank you thank you all members and
we've not got
much left to go um item eight's been
dealt with unless there's anything
adrian needs to add
i'm going to um item 9 share
maybe my agendas yeah item 8 was the
late representations report so that
wouldn't be dealt with at this stage and
uh
members received item nine now yes
thank you do you just want to
make one comment on the appeals sheriff
members will indulge me
yep go ahead the there were just two
two appeals reported this month chairs
members will have seen
and it's the allowed appeal which i did
just want to
bring to members attention and just to
encourage you
again if you've not already done so to
give that a read
i wish um i could um
be more helpful in directing members on
how that helps you in your decision
making but it's a decision
to to grant consent for housing
at horfield gate lane and it is in
contrast to the recent
decision handed down at netherland road
the a61 at tucton which was dismissed
his members will recall
in this instance at horfield gate lane
the inspector
set out that the tilted balance was
engaged which
weighs in favor of granting commission
for for housing
and came to that conclusion then as i
say granted consent
it's interesting also the comments that
the inspector made with regards to your
publication draft local plan which
inspector grey gave moderate weight to i
do think it does
we emphasize the importance of having an
up-to-date development plan despite the
fact we have
in excess of our five years rolling
housing land supply chair but
i would encourage members to read of
that
the importance of weighing up your
development plan policies
when making decisions on planning
applications it's it's
it is an interesting uh it is an
interesting read if
you're stuck for something to do for
five minutes
thank you thank you any comments on that
for adrian
well item 10 is matter of urgency which
i have
none unless anybody else has anything
they want to bring up
thank you all very much for this
afternoon and i'll see you again soon
take care
you